[Music]
nightm nightmare I can see it's a
nightmare it's a nightmare it's a
nightmare I
can guys today is not just
Friday but it is also uh an exciting
Monumental day your hands up in the air
please because
today we have taken this meme all the
way over the
cliff we hit the wall we went through
the wall and over the cliff with this
meme today is the
dreams song remix tournament
yay I have been looking forward to this
unironically since we announced it I
love these kinds of episodes me too and
you can always count on the audience
members just such talents yeah such
phenomenal people out there I mean truly
only the best only the best and glad we
get to enjoy it every once in a while
yeah and they're they are really good so
we'll be doing we'll jump into that soon
it's I imagine it's going to take a
little bit of time to work through that
but I will say to the winner of the
tournament that the grand prize is that
you are going to make this an official
collaboration with dreams wait is that
confirmed no it's not confirmed well
hold on I didn't finish I didn't finish
I didn't finish it's not confirmed I
haven't asked him yet okay let me finish
but I feel like there's a good chance
you might be down okay it's an
announcement of intention yeah it's like
the it's like the uh the Mr what was it
the that you want Ian Mr
verified yeah it's not a guarantee I
haven't even asked him [__] yeah but
he's going to call in later at around 4:
to
uh help us CR the winner and I'll and
I'll ask him
then and he'll definitely be on the spot
I mean if he's on live was he going to
say no when better to do it if not put
him on the spot of
course um but I think when he hear what
is that from yeah why you toing me
Z why you tooting me bro tooting you
yeah why you hitting me with the [__]
it's a toot it's not a fart no it's not
a fart you know what a toot is a horn
sound man it's also a fart speaking of
which there's a new fart gate Ethan that
we need to confront you about today a
new what a new fart gate oh there is
it's a pretty compelling it's pretty
good you're done oh my God G oh by the
way before we get into that was I here
or was I not here no no before we get
into fartgate
and I don't mind the comparison to Wendy
Williams she is my idol my Northern
Light I am sick obviously so bear with
me my throat is pretty [__] up I
wasn't feeling good on Wednesday then
you took a rest day yeah it wasn't much
of a rest day
thday at all I used my voice a lot which
I wasn't supposed to do but I did it and
so now my voice is pretty [__] up and
I wasn't going to miss this episode
there's no hell goddamn way you know so
that's that also I want to announce
quickly here at the top because we don't
have sponsors and we are hated around
the world by
all that today now I don't know I just
I'm I'm playing it up a bit I'm being a
little dramatic just that we we're just
having a hard time getting sponsors
lately gotcha I'll sponsor you sponsored
by my wife the next one's by my mom
butterflies Teddy fresh Black Friday
sale we like to do our black sale Black
Friday sale early folks because we don't
believe that you need to be bumping
shoulders and crunching skulls to get
yourself a killer deal Teddy fresh.com
Black Friday sale up to 60% off let me I
mean let's see Ela um and um our team
did it by like colar scheme oh is that
kind of fun so by the way this shirt
here which is fire was 60 now it's 30
yeah somebody's losing money here the
owners are [__] nuts
dude um was 85 is now 34 fire stop
that's an old hoodie that we found we
realized we still had some stock of it
oh really yeah I yeah I remember I love
this hoodie I remember when we made
it it's interesting how that happened
yeah that's uh so many classic styles to
choose
from so many
phenomenal
sets the vibe
with right Ela hell
yeah go on um let's see oh God this
shirt is so sick cor shirt yeah I love
this shirt so much are you sure this
should be on
sale I don't know it's a little too late
we can undo it can we Undo It message
message Ecom we have to undo this it's
too crazy it's rewind time it's I need
to it's an
emergency um trust
nobody I personally love that slogan
yeah me too oh that shirt you just
scrolled by let me go down that one on
the right one of my favorites I wear it
all the time I see people like it I yeah
people wear it they love it you got the
purple you got the black brown
brown thank you it's actually like oh
thanks
Dan um there's so much great shirts uh
that one on the top right this one I
love this sh that's an Ethan shirt dude
it's so designed with Ethan in mind so
sick so guys head on over there's just
pages and pages of awesome there's so
much um it's 14 pages so go ahead Teddy
fresh.com check it out I mean there's so
much to shop
them thank you thank you Luke had
mentioned that they did something about
you could sort it by like size and stuff
how you do that we just updated the
and so there's more how do I do it by
size cuz that's cool oh [__] by size so
you can filter by size so let's say
you're like a real tight little you're
small you're you're a tight little fella
so you would want you could even pick
like four options it looks like you
could pick we have xxs list say we do if
it's unisex sometimes we go down to XX
small let's say you're a big boy 3XL
okay yeah and you you don't want to look
through all this [__] let's see what do
we got what's on the menu these are all
in 3XL but you also left the extra small
check but sure oh [__] see this is this
is a this is a unlikely couple the 3XL
and the XS together
XXX so here it is Big Boys Rejoice
little boys Rejoice ladies in between
everywhere non-binaries everybody of all
sizes and shapes M mhm
t.com thank you high five thank
you um can I ask for a make
good God from you too what did I do
wrong you didn't read read the URL at
the end no actually you did all right
fine you get makeup just joking these
Brands you know I I bent over backwards
to go oh you did that one literally came
to me and said you did that ad to early
somebody said that yeah we we want to
make a they should love that
right and I'm like okay dude it's not
like we have bunch of sponsors and
there's no inventory so yeah take them
[__] make
good [__]
anyway uh Dan go ahead with
fartgate fart gate oh another thing
sorry another thing Love's Dad is here
oh
yeah big love Love's Dad is in is
visiting hello
h h hul h h that's right not not at all
imagine the bird a haulk Hulk hul like a
hawk yeah yeah oh like a hwk h then a
can H yeah so the American way would be
like hwan yeah hwen hwen excellent okay
I like that cool name it is cool HW you
he got a cool hawk sound Zach you can
play when he talks
I can I'll find one
yeah yeah that'll be good make sure it's
not an eagle but an actual haulk it's a
we need a hawk Zach it's a right away
sir I Got My BT on the mute mute switch
here now love uh I T I first met uh
Hawkin when I came in and he was
cracking me up he was making me laugh
and he's a fan of the show he watches it
but love there was a little bit of
tension because love I sense there was
some embar
going on where you didn't want him to
sit with you well I feel safe since I
have the mute button but no yeah this is
awful
painful I'm scared I'm wored H huckin
why is it that you think he's
embarrassed uh potentially to have you
on the mic well
well I'm him ah you don't you
don't more
mature and so the other way around them
so you're you're the two point0 yeah and
I'm the love are you and I know you're
really you understand Mike etiquette I
know you're not putting it up to his
mouth for on purpose yeah just an arms
length you know just make
sure he's holding the mic yeah his hand
is on the mic um is that right love is
that possible that uh in in your father
you see a reflection of yourself you're
looking at a mirror and uh and and more
mature version of yourself my dad's
favorite pastime is to make me cringe as
much as possible we go to the grocery
store he'll like say things loud he'll
he'll like just embarrass me and now
it's just Amplified it's just awful a
that's kind of sweet I do think that's
part of what a Dad's job
is it's too embarrass ah hin go ahead
Zach what that was really good that's
not good enough for you well
yeah not a Swedish Hawk but what's a
Swedish hwk sound like hey hold on I
think I think I all right and and well
by the way my name has nothing to do
with a Hulk well it does know it it's
it's a name of the Kings oh that's even
cooler it's a name of a king of a
Swedish
it means name of the king old timey King
name Vikings and stuff so anyway um
Hawkin will be joining us today and uh
it's bound to be
fun one and one thing that I can say
love is that he hasn't had any of the uh
iconic uh American fast food yet you may
oh my goodness he hasn't really had
anything right and I and love love had
mentioned that you guys have a similar
palette oh to a certain extent I suppose
yeah fast food there a reason you put
cheese on a sandwich you put cheese you
take bread you put cheese on it yeah
that's the then you call it a day yeah
well love love won't even do cheese what
are you talking about dude yeah love
doesn't even eat cheese yeah yeah he he
he sort of evolved away next Generation
my dad doesn't like veggies that much
either is that
right well a Haw Hawks are predators
they don't eat veggies
either I believe what blamed his um his
weird unusual eating habits perhaps on
you I believe at one point do you accept
that criticism or not do you accept that
or no except what that love says he's
got his weird eating habits from
you yeah perhaps I don't know I I tried
to train him when he was young and
including cooking and stuff like that
but didn't stick uh no I think he just
never really rein enforced anything so I
just no I mean I had the option to eat
burgers and I ate Burgers no Sal my
mother forced me to eat the veggies and
stuff and I hated it so there you go
you're free you're liberated so you're
breaking this the cycle the cycle of of
of generational trauma she hid stuff in
the food and I know I knew it so I okay
if I dig I will find some [__]
mushrooms or carrots or whatever and if
I found it I wouldn't eat it right I
like that and I didn't want to put him
in and love do you have any idea where
should we start with uh feeding your
father something today well I don't know
he likes you like pizza he actually has
no clue what tacos is or anything
Mexican yeah I mean that's exciting he
Le like Sweden a taco is like um
cucumber corn what yeah and salad how
like a lettuce I don't know it's weird
oh it's in lettuce like a lettuce Taco
yeah we have lettuce on on there that
sounds it's very it's like the whitest
Taco you could imagine Friday the
further you get away from Mexico the
more [__] up it get so he never he
does he has no clue what authentic
Mexican food is so do you want to get
him Taco Bell or do you want to order
actual like uh Taco Bell seems fitting
but I don't
know what do you think you want fast
food or you want like some people to
cook it for
you love likes the fast food one I think
yeah it's not bad I mean you know yeah
yeah I take whatever we'll do both let's
do
both okay the the the the cine tacle and
the fast food tackle we need a or what
which ones the fancy cuine tackle and
the fast food tackle we'll do both oh
we'll do both yeah we'll do both the
fancy Cuisine is the guys by the road in
their tents and cars right yeah yeah
that is the good stuff yeah I told him
about the white white tent T Street
Benders there is a lot street food yep
so um fantastic so very nice to have you
here nice to be here thank you very much
and um and you're here for a week is
that right yeah so he'll be here on
Monday and Wednesday as well yeah I'll
be here every
day every day
every day okay all the
time day no he will not be in the studio
I'll leave him at
home oh and by the way Haw and apologies
about the S Stroman accident that in
your house yeah the house smelt like
shipped for like couple of
days and I mean uh yeah it was bad I
apologize I apologize you remember you
gave him 50 bucks
I my he felt so bad for me cuz I had to
I I ate parts of it so he let me keep it
the 50 bucks you gave to him for the for
the
trouble wait wait no that's not okay you
didn't you couldn't eat it but I so I
split the 50 between you and your dad or
the you gave 50 bucks to my dad nice but
he let me keep it but I mean but I mean
suam doesn't it's not bad if eaten
correctly oh see I was going to ask you
so you are I mean it stinks but uh you
remove the stink and it's just
fish that's true if you have a boomer
mouth no taste that's a true Boomer
mindset sounds
like when have how many times have you
eaten suum strowman in your life like
that u 10 times perhaps 10 that's way
more than I thought yeah work it's like
a day every we every year you have the S
string day and do you do you go you eat
a lot of it or is it just like a crack
no no it's disgusting
yeah it's bad bad tasting fish yeah it
can't be that nice fish it's bad
fish some people like it we have S
strowman here we still have a can no
no you guys seem to have this amazing uh
Swedish pride and I just wonder why it
stops when it's time to bring out the s
strowman i I feel like it's a dying
generation you know no no no one under
30 eats
it definitely not North I think they do
maybe yeah up north anyway thank you
everybody thank you to hofton thank you
to
love thank you to everyone at
home and I took nightquil two nights in
a row
and it that [__] [__] me up dude like
I couldn't I would like wake up this
morning and think that I was going to be
up and then I'd fall asleep again in 5
minutes I did that like all morning it
was a
nightmare a nightmare a nightmare I
can't sleep it's a nightmare a nightmare
a nightmare I
can you're
night you're not there all right 800
still great o capella do the fart gate D
yeah you ready to answer for your crimes
a good light were you wait hold on Turn
Turn It Up nice and loud on the monitor
please
Zach Jesus all right here we go in a
good light were you
concerned about how what happened in a
good light Len were you
concerned about that's not a what is
that in a good light were you
concerned there's no way I ripped ass
like that about how that could be an
alfredo burp yeah that's what Olivia
said it could be I've heard Alfredo burp
like that before it could be any number
of things you know I
have like I genuinely here's what I want
to do the next time I actually genuinely
have a fart I feel like most of your
farts are either silent or very loud
thank you and it's about intention I
have that control you do yeah thank
you so here's what I want to do Dan
before you further accuse me that's
totally alred the next time that I have
to fart I will alert you guys everybody
I will fart as loudly as I can and they
can hear it listen this was a report
that we received and we deemed it worthy
investigation there's been no accusation
here but it's worth examining now Zach
is playing a enhanced version of
[Music]
it I mean it could it could it could be
anything sounds like the intro to beat
it almost anything but a fart I feel
like anything but a fart Ela said in
fact she's she can't
conceive J I mean we can do a we can do
a poll if you want all right let's do a
poll I mean it is
democracy this sounds
crazy for the record I don't think it's
necessarily a fart yeah the the enhanced
version I I feel like it doesn't really
sound like a fart sounds like I don't
know maybe it is alfredo or
something yes
no here we go
and here we
go uh did Ethan fart yes or
no I'm going to say no yeah man it's
really okay that was not me that was
added wow this is almost split evenly
52%
surprised say no Ethan didn't not F and
I thank you guys for for supporting me
on this oh people are already start
starting to call me corrupt in this
situation unbiased
biased no you have no reason to protect
me anyway we'll we'll see I we'll we'll
do a more scientific experiment on this
I just got to keep it real sounds like
go all
right um people are wondering how my mom
found the name she was really wanted to
think I have no idea how she really
wanted to thank Emerald I'm I I'm sorry
forget the other her the other uh aara
and wonderful lady's name aara and
emerald my mom was like you have to put
me you have to put me in touch I have to
thank
them and so I was like well here's her
here's her Tik Tok she maybe she follows
you so she I guess she did and my mom
sent her hi Melissa and
Julie this is Ethan's Mom Donna I wanted
to thank you both for the pink quz
butterfly it's lovely and it now sits on
my nightstand holding my rings I take
off every evening thanks again that was
very
thoughtful I really need to know where
she got these names from so wait are
they denying that it's their
name yeah they're saying it's not their
name because well I don't know if they
found like their government name or
something oh I cannot call my mom I that
was kind of my
plan um
why would they find the government name
from a Tik Tok account Mark Jeff Julia
Melissa all right let me call and find
out what
happened
um one of the top comments here her son
doesn't have the best track record with
correct
names probably from him but it's
actually not from you I didn't do that
don't [__] put that on me why is it
calling from
Instagram what the [__] what here look
look I type my mom's
name call Instagram why is it doing that
that's weird I can't call my mom you you
don't have her number saved of course I
do she has you
blocked Mom I'm
sorry oh here it was under the right
one's mom not
Don all right let's get to the bottom of
this hello Mom I'm live
oh hi let me turn up the radio Alexis
stop hello
[Music]
so
Jesus Christ maybe it was funny maybe I
should have left Jesus
Christ that seemed like a bit oh my God
I should have left it shouldn't I have
what oh my
God funny you can't write that [__] that
so comments everyone that was open
to Mom I wasn't talking that wasn't what
I was talking about oh oh oh I'm sorry
okay I that's not the topic of today's
conversation oh okay I was looking at
okay sorry go
ahead oh
[__] I wish I didn't button it out now
because it was just so
funny anyway whatever listen mom yes you
insisted on thinking emerald
and AAR you blocked out again you
insisted on what thanking emerald and
lazara the aara AAR emerald and Azara
that the call your mom you don't know
the names the stone
ladies oh yeah you know what I I wanted
to thank them and so I you know I was
looking for their name everywhere
because I didn't want to just say hey
girls I wanted to address them
personally and so um I was busy doing
bunch of stuff and I said hey you know I
was talking to your dad can you get on
in Instagram or whatever and find their
page and find out what their names are
and so dad told me what their names were
and so I said Thank
you and so and so Dad told you so they
posted and said you called them Melissa
and
Julie um but apparently j u l i e Julie
did it why did it say jewelry no no no
Melissa and Julie aren't their names so
they were like why they said where did
they get these names from
oh you know what where did Dad get the
names from I have no idea because I was
busy you know house and I asked him well
Dad's shopping right now he food
shopping but yeah I because I I couldn't
find their names anywhere right you know
when I was I was
everywhere I couldn't find oh I'm sure
it's on their website Melissa and Julie
well when he gets back let me know you
can you can let Dan know in the in the
chat room we have and then we can they
probably thought I was a real weirdo
because I I didn't get their names right
no no no no not at all they love you all
right that's it Mom uh all right love
you I'll talk to you soon okay sorry no
no no no Mom a that was sad S no no you
didn't do anything wrong it was just it
was it's silly it's fun it's fun happy
times they're they're everyone's happy
I'll ask Dad where he got the names from
do you want him to call you or send you
a text I'd prefer a call okay yeah I'll
have him call you all right thanks Mom
okay babe all right talk to you later
bye bye
sheesh can't believe that [__] what
she said oh my God
I can't believe
this um moving
on uh their actual names are emerald
Azara and Nat so thank you to them my
mom was trying to thank you guys ab's a
liar why would someone say that about
you AB I have no idea what is this this
is a Hot Topic on the the subreddit
you're not
liar but well let's watch that do you
have one ab and Lena you guys doing the
pet name thing uh no I mean I call her
Lenny and no one really calls her Lenny
and also that's not a pet name no yeah
Snips snip Snips is one we knew about
the Snips one because she broke your
dick you been calling me that way before
way before wait why why snip the way I
think when we work together at a
restaurant like she can never be mean to
anyone she just sometimes we get a
little snippy
oh little snipp why you why are you
playing Jewish music Zach cuz you said
snip like a [__] mo
mo I get I see get on my level bro I see
it I see
it that that explanation actually makes
sense it's deep
humor he's like 10 steps ahead of us all
the time [__]
do I haven't seen have you ever wondered
why Anakin calls Ahsoka Snips it's
actually a call back to the Clone Wars
movie from 2008 and it actually comes
right after Ahsoka calls Anakin Sky guy
for the first time you're stu with me
Sky guy does she call you Sky guy she
definitely does
not
okay why did you just call me don't get
snippy with me little one from this
point forward because Ahsoka was snippy
do this have any relation to do I know
you guys are big I mean they literally
dressed up as those two characters like
a week ago and I'm so [__] ashamed of
my Star Wars fandom I hit it and I lied
and I made up an excuse cuz I don't have
a big ass Vader in my background uh yeah
my videos so did you get it from this
show sniff no I really don't think I did
I mean they back then for the record
Ahsoka was a kid so that means this girl
that I really liked I gave her the
nickname of a kid character which is
really [__] weird but wait why did
you say that you shouldn't have even
said
that you didn't need to put that out
there yeah well no it's also it's weird
because like it's a master Apprentice uh
relationship and at the time I was the
manager of the restaurant L it was a
waitress interesting also no he called
me that before we saw the show Clone
Wars which is when she say when he gives
her that nickname Snips we are you had
he seen it well we watched it together
didn't we or did you yeah we did watch
it together I don't know if I watched a
little bit before you okay maybe I don't
know but maybe that's where I got the
snip from I don't know the subliminal
the subliminal maybe yeah when I heard
it in the show I was like and I told AB
I'm like did you hear that he calls her
Snips and and he was like oh yeah that's
weird and Lena you're denying that you
have a pet name for ab I don't yeah it's
just AB you just call him AB mhm H right
not that there's anything wrong with pet
names if I had one I'd share it mhm
you're not embarrassed no not sky man
not Sky guy a sky guy so ab's not a liar
you you are sky
guy guy guy [__] but um there it is you
know AB is not a liar okay now why now
here they go he downplays that he got
the Star Killer name from Star Wars when
Ethan asked him why he picked that name
in another episode is that true was it
the lie that's for potential legal
[Music]
reasons star
okay I you're absolved you know what I
mean this is I'm you're acquitted man
thank you you're off the by the power
vested in
me but yes I I love Star Wars just just
saying who's your unrelated yeah who's
your favorite Star Wars character Darth
Revan how about that nerd [__] that's
not even in the movies that's the right
answer wait Darth who exactly Darth
Revan exactly when is Darth Revan
getting a show 4,000 years before the
movies nights of the Old Republic from
video game was he a baddie uh it's
complicated it's complicated he was he
was a goodie that went bad and then came
back and then became Revan the redeemed
that's a real hero's journey oh yeah
yeah I love that that's what got dude
everyone knows Jar Jar Binks is the
greatest [__] Star Wars bro Jar Jar
Binks can swim hella fast he's goated
bro he does not get enough
Love Char Binks today would not fly
right cuz I I thought it was like a
little patronizing cuz it's like a
Jamaican accent and I would never it got
criticized at the time it was it was
ever ever do a Jama yeah you would never
do something so offensive um yeah no
even even when that movie came out
people I wasn't even thinking about that
yeah
right the one guy the uh what's his name
Zach the guy who the merchant who owns
Anakin oh the uh w
w yeah that was like some racist [__]
right there um moving on to Sam whoever
that
is who's Sam Sam now I I know there's
like a viral song going around Tik Tok
is but I thought this was a cover but is
this an original that is an original oh
this is an
original yep it's definitely inspired by
a lot of other songs in a similar vein
but I did write that one this is all you
girl okay okay well that's exciting I
haven't seen this and I'm not going to
get claimed okay good I see it's been
checked I'm not going to get claimed by
Samantha disco
[Music]
Kid last night we let the rler talk even
Livy done was getting rised up by baby
gron he said that her G was so Ohio and
SK even Ka I show speed hitting the
gritty a grim is Shake
fornite
y a g shaking
yo wait I want the whole song it's so
good W hold on I want the whole ass song
don't tease me like
that D that was good you have a
beautiful voice too all right I was I
was not trying to sing please girl you
were hitting those notes like here like
this you had a wonderful tonal change
here rised up by baby gron that was so
SM
was beautiful that was so smooth by baby
Gro and you're so right liby Dunn was
getting rised up by baby gr I remember I
remember remember never forget was there
a Grimace Shake in fortnite no I wish
there was though that's why the song
that's why you sing it
manifesting that's what you someone made
a remix the next link it's crazy it's
actually pretty catchy oh okay the remix
is thank God they autotune me you sound
so fire on that
track
[Music]
see last
theed Up by Baby
[Music]
heit the
a g shaking
fornite a g shaking
fortnite a g shaking
fortnite wow
Harmon Shing
fortnite a g shaking fortnite
that's Beau wow wow it it it hits me on
an emotional level that is such a
vibe that seems like something fortnite
would be interested in bringing the
Grimace Shake into the
world of fortnite may I ask what is the
grimmest shake oh
Ela oh
Boomer Boomer Boomer
so McDonald's made I didn't like half of
the lyrics I don't understand that's
kind of the joke I
gu um you have to be like crazy internet
Boomer literate to understand anything
she said but anyway Grimace was his
birthday or some [__] and McDonald's put
out a purple Grimace Shake okay and then
all the Zoomers on Tik Tok started doing
gags like they would drink it and
die and so that was like a big trend for
a while it was actually a quality
milkshake it was very good I never tried
it it was like blueberry flavored with
vanilla mhm I mean is it him though like
it's purple and it's him it's like the
he came in it he came it is his
ejaculate it's his no it's his flesh how
you going to collect this much
ejaculate Grimace be
[__] have you g that that guy [__]
dude the old Grim is purple all right
all right that guy Mer's stud he's a
stud nickname is Ivan who oh no all
right uh shout out to Josh verelli For
That Remix by the way mhm that was also
good thank
you um again people are always trying to
expose me I hate when people go through
all my old tweets my old videos and be
like look you've changed and you know
you used to be like racist and
homophobic and like just trying to dig
up and make all these crazy accusations
against me and I just wish you guys
would stop doing that um Boba what kind
of boba I love
Boba I love Boba me
too sometimes the Boba is not sweet
enough bro I don't like that when it's
like tasteless this quote dude what
happened to I have an explanation man
what happened to you I was talking about
the the gems are not sweet enough the
gems the pearls the pearls that's cool
the B the Bobo the B pears are not sweet
enough the drink itself is too
sweet both things can be true at once
people not this one not everything it
needs to be an
exposed um that's what I'm saying thanks
bro Hawkin have you had
Boba uh unfortunately yeah you don't
like no what don't you like about it
it's [__] in the drink it's just [__] in
the drink we like our drinks without
[__] in it yeah yeah I mean a drink is a
drink it's not not like porridge or do
you like smoothie with a spoon or soup
do you like drink do you like smoothies
smoothies does it soup be drink
strawberry perhaps this a soupy
drink yeah so you're
retracting okay okay I see what I've
cornered you okay yeah uh
some [__] is good and some is not okay I
see yeah although and to to speak on
your
defense the shake is still more of a
beverage where the the the pearls you
have to chew on it you know yeah they
they they uh that's they stick in the
strawberry and stuff yeah oh straw they
get stuck in there what what what uh you
just lost the audience uh Hawkin go
ahead love speak your
mind just telling him to hurry up to
wrap it up wrap it up boys next topic I
don't
like oh my
God I father son relationships are so
beautiful aren't they I love them I have
sons myself two sons a third on the way
yeah yeah yeah is is love an only child
uh yeah it it CHS doesn't
it [__] god oh [__] taken
out and and but that's not his fault
that's your fault yeah that's a me yeah
come do you wish you had siblings love
no
no well I guess it worked out cousin
cousins yeah nice love that I just want
to say I've known older love for like a
couple hours now and he's the [__]
[__] I like him a lot I think he's
really funny and cool dude he's been
yapping annoying everyone in here I
don't think so important things to do
and it's like just yapping D I learned a
lot whoa who
what I did what why oh I'll say in in
defense of love now cuz I have a dad
that embarrasses me a lot and he's also
someone that likes to schmoo and talk to
everybody and so I would be in a room
with my dad and everyone would be like
your dad's great I love your dad and I
would be so embarrassed because they
don't know my dad they think he's cool
because they've just they all just
touched the
surface is that what you is that kind of
how you feel I think so well yeah I
don't know I just think I don't know I
don't know really I don't I don't have
any we don't need to Psycho analyze too
uh too deeply just think think he likes
to talk that's all yeah that's beautiful
we love we love talkers
MH we love
Hawks
um
J shett needs to get the [__] out of my
life dude what's he doing now dude what
isn't he doing one he now he's got a
school like he's trying to promote J
shed certific school that I heard about
no this is Jay he put his [__] name
in the title so arrogant J shett
certific C certification school oh he's
starting one what are you certifying
Jay how to be
shitty how to be thank thank
you I bet I have more to teach people
than him at least I'm real about
it you know Jay shete wants to give you
a whole monologue about why you're
[__] lonely and broke I'll just you
know I'll just cut right to the chase
that's my
school
mhm it's called the Ethan Klein crash
course get your [__] together clean your
room clean your room
man so he's got this but this is isn't
all he's got this man is now even in the
shopping malls why is he in a gap ad
he's he's in the Gap window oh wait can
you find the Gap window one this is an
ad he's yeah here here he is another ad
for [__] Gap huh check this [__]
out that's him and his wife oh they look
great dude they are glazed the [__] up
they are beautiful glaz you have to be
glazed to appear in this commercial and
I don't know what's going on below the
shete Horizon but there's turbulence
there there is turbulence behind those
beautiful blue eyes oh yeah it's not
just Gap he was in a BMW ad as well give
me that I need all of it my man's on top
of the world right now you guys know
what it's like to be
hated to
be Behind Blue Eyes [__] in a
BMW commercial this is is my car my
dream not only I drive this car not only
your car this is advertised on our on
podcast oh what the [__] he's inside
your walls brother what are you doing
how why is why are you don't aren't you
busy man yeah it's busy getting paid
huge sponsorships
yeah his shit's not pop more popular
than ours like if you look at the Edison
[__] shed's not above us not even close
I mean so that's what I'm saying where I
don't get the proof is in the BM nothing
I get
nothing the lies man what can I say well
here let me tell you this BMW I drive
that car and I [__] hate it it sucks
it's so annoying it drives fine but the
like interior and the electronic systems
and all this [__] it
sucks it
sucks it's it it's it
oh [__] and I knew that they would come
love since you sent me that video y when
we were still waiting for the car I
warned you it was already happening it
was already in motion and then love sent
this video about somebody showing how
the cars like got some really dumb stuff
going on in it and just they didn't take
the time to perfect it yeah and then I
knew it that the day it's only the clock
is sticking
until Ethan is going to be complaining
about this car every day I hate it makes
me so angry let me give you an example I
was pulling out this happened to me
twice I was pulling out on my way to
work making the first turn okay now the
passenger drawer which I didn't touch it
appeared closed when I got in mhm but it
was not
closed okay M and so when I got in the
car was it I turned on
[Music]
was the door AAR I don't know if it was
like lightly lashed or a jar but either
way a [__] Honda Accord from 19
[__] 80 would tell me would warn me
that the door isn't closed when I turn
the engine on right so I turned the car
on there's no sound there's no
indication mhm I don't think I think
that I think it might have actually
thought the car door was closed beep and
so I pull out I turn at a normal SP
speed and the door swings [__] wide
open like wide all the way out so super
dangerous so dangerous it's scary as
[__] I was like whated
twice BMW you need to stop spending your
money on J shett as and return it back
into research and development you're
dropping the [__] ball man also it
has the most annoying thing where if you
leave the car it or like you just step
out of the car it immediately locks all
the doors and so I have to have my bag
with me at all times because if I exit
and then I want to open the back door to
get the kids out the doors are locked
lock the kids in everything and your bag
if I if I go around to get if I don't
have my bag with me it's all locked yes
if I there's no way to get in you're
right if I leave my bag in the car close
the door and then go around to get the
kids they're all locked in the [__]
car dude y I've never seen
anything BMW's been dropping the ball
yeah I expected more that I expected
more like even like their other um non
EV cars I I've heard a bunch of issues
about
too what's happening what's going on I
don't know man they're German right oh
yeah they are yeah they are German
what's happening to the German Empire
there's better German Brands like what
Mercedes Porsche Audi mhm are they not
all owned by like the same [__] yacht
uh Porsche and Audi are owned by
VW vdubs vdubs anyway J shett [__]
you love you I'm
pissed he's so nice to me by the way
meanwhile he's so nice to me he's a
great guy he goes I'm he goes I'm so
happy we finally get to connect
such a pleasant man you don't know what
it's like to be
hated Behind Blue Eyes but my
doors they won't open they won't swing
open and my
neighbor life is in
danger yeah I know
it anyway more shete uh stuff what do we
got this man was in
a here this is this now this is a
[__] ad this car sucks as a piece of
[__] been fine yeah I wonder why they
don't hire you I wouldn't have said that
if they paid
me if they paid me it' be all rainbows
and
butterflies now that's an ad that's a
pre-roll can we make
that we pleas make that shoot a fake
commercial we should make about all the
stuff we hate about this car there's so
much that may be it doesn't even have a
Frank okay it does have a Frank what
kind of an electric card doesn't have a
front the first time I've heard that in
my life the [__] is a front front TR
it's a front TR because when you're
electric then you don't need the front
wait wait but you have you have a lot of
trunk space no it's tiny oh really dude
it's smaller even when I have a frun I
never use it but I like knowing that
it's there no sometimes you do though
you do use it like you're telling me BMW
in this [__] like whatever SUV
couldn't make space for a frunk and
meanwhile you got all these little like
twink um electric vehicles and they got
frks they do can I say that Olivia like
can I use twink in that way I was having
this conversation the other day I'm not
sure honestly I know that um I've heard
like Hassan use it
and he's talked about using it and it
being okay and you've used it well I'm
not a gay man I feel like every time you
use it you get in trouble so maybe
there's something to learn not use for
I've looked in chat and people don't say
stuff but I I wonder do a PO on boy I
don't I mean let's just get to the to
the bottom of it you know I think it's
import it's important to learn actually
I'm not I think it's a really I like the
word and I like the it just say it's a
lot of it's love I feel like expresses a
lot when there is doubt
then eliminate the doubt right so just
don't use it just say when in doubt
don't say it
yeah if I lived by that
Ela I would have never made it in this
business just saying okay uh Ethan use
the word
twink um of oh my goodness okay okay
wait this it's rapidly changing this is
a highly Dynamic environment I'm not
going to vote because who am I to say
well amongst those who are voting 72%
say yes I can say
twink I want to be a
twink I do I wish I was a twink I'm
getting closer every day though although
I don't think I can be a twink cuz I
have too much hair in my body right
you're also not a gay
man right that is a pre that's a
prerequisite it seems like U I don't
know if you need to be I don't see
anybody that's saying that you cannot
say
it people are saying say twink more
often oh stop
it wait is let me let me gay let me
Define twink Define
twink among gay men a gay or bisexual
man with a slim build and youthful
appearance okay so yeah you're right
then it does is gay or bisexual man love
you slim and Youthful the fact that that
is not me describing a gay person feels
charged I feel like we shouldn't just
say it they told they but I got the pass
I got the twink pass that's a big game
man I got the twink
card don't take that from
me people are saying I'm more of a
bear that's true yeah yeah you would
well you would fall more into that
category to find bear in homosexual I
don't know I feel like sweet in gay
culture a bear is a larger or often
hairier man who checks an image of
rugged masculinity so I hate to be the
ver okay you check some of those rugged
Mas the fat and hairy part I
check rugged and
masculine so like I basically take the
worst attributes of both of
them just basically
unfuckable undatable your
strain Sigma Behavior
um somebody said that you give otter
Vibes which I heard of wa what does that
mean that sounds cute I'm the resident
otter here oh okay oh that that that
position's taken S I don't think I you
take you take a offense with me being
well here let me let me I just looked it
up cuz I was not familiar OT uh within
uh the gay community otter is a term
describe a type of gay man they
generally have a lot of body hair much
like bears but are small smaller in
frame and or weight considerably less
than Bears okay so it's a twink bear
that is what you
are it's just a tweet that is
hairy and yeah it sounds but that's that
is you cim that's what saying he's
saying it's seats taken dude but but you
say I can't be an otter we can have a
couple otter why can't I be an otter too
can you just don't fit the bill I don't
think so what am I the bill I don't know
am I a cub maybe I don't know a cub a
cub you're
rectangular the bear a cub is that a
thing yeah okay let me look it up bear
cub meaning gay
community a sloth a chub it's I see oh a
cub is a younger so there's two
definitions that are associated a chub
is a heavy set man who might be
described as overweight or obese these
men are also a distinct subculture
within the gay community may or may not
identify with with the bear movement per
se Cubs is a younger or younger looking
version of a bear sometimes but not
always with a smaller
frame I the terminology they use is f w
you're a cob like I want do they all fit
into some kind of animal hierarchy what
if you don't belong well twink isn't
yeah I mean true they're not all animal
there's also twunk too which is the's
twk some people were saying that you're
a twk a a twunk a hunky a twunk yeah
they were just making it up twk is just
kind of a fun word to say twk Define twk
like a baby twk
twonk then there's wolves wolves wait
are you serious what's uh twank is it's
just a fat
twink is that what a twank is no it's a
a strong one oh it's
a okay and then you said a wolf a wolf I
think I'm just typing Define wolf gay
community you know let's see I think
it's an
older oh that makes sense a wolf is a
gay male who is semi hairy muscular lean
attractive and sexually
aggressive like a like a cougar yeah
sure yeah that's actually a good
comparison o so interesting so many
different it just sounds like we're
starting to describe just different
people at this point not really
archetypes I think I might like to get
picked up by a
wolf I like the
description I'll be your prey
baby too much no I'm serious that sounds
sounds like a good option for
me uh let's see oh did you send the J
shett in the [__] Gap ad yeah I'll
I'll resend it one sec oh here it is
thing I got it I just scroll up it was
and then he's in the [__] shopping
mall man he's in a damn window of Gap
like I'm sorry Gap I'm not walking in
your store just nice his me too look at
those both drawing me in they're like
both of them they're both incredible
they ey racist and I'll tell you why I
believe that they're straight up these
people the fact that they found each
other with these beautiful unique eyes
means that they were both excluding the
massive general population of brown eyed
or even blue and Hazel dyed that don't
have this kind of beautiful exceptional
eye color in your opinion they have c as
a Hazel ey that's hard statement to put
up cosign this as a Hazel eye you're
what you have you have beauti you have
blues or Hazel they're blue Hazel like
mine they might be
Hazels I've been told that they're blue
well well well we got really
nitty-gritty with the defition we we
kind of discovered that pretty much
anybody can say they have haal eyes
except
Ethan she does you have green in
there blue Hazel like me there's a
mix means you're hazed up dens are about
as blue as blue can get nope they're no
they're blue Hazel yeah they're
Hazel I'm Hazel too my mom says we have
the same eye
color but anyway you know I mean shame
on you gab for promoting this where is
the eye inclusivity right that's it
that's
it hold on hold on hold on what my kids
are going to walk by this Gap and look
at these beautiful eyes and what do they
how what do they think about themselves
in their eye color they all have brown
eyes mhm your kids yeah your kids have
beautiful Haz they're brown they're
brown as [__] just like me you know
these boys I don't know the jeans are as
strong mine are dominant yeah when it
comes to well I feel that Bruce really
got dominated by my jeans more than
Teddy because Teddy has like really
beautiful straight hair and and Brucey
Cur like curly hair I hope that it's
like really curly that's going to be so
cute although I will say Bruce's hair is
so cute yeah it is so [__] cute
you'll have like just a couple of curls
like so he is so so so cute I love my
boys um but then but you know who I
don't love is
these
racist I'm kidding I that's too harsh
they're not I'm sure that they're really
really not
that what are the chances that two
people with these eye colors found each
other in the world so beautiful it's
like unbelievable do they have kids I
hope so they're going to the most
beautiful people I've ever se you know
their kids are going to be born brown
eyes and then be like what did I do in
my past life I think it makes sense for
them to wind up together they they they
saw each other from across the room
locked eyes you know how could you not I
mean who's good enough for someone with
eyes that beautiful for I think it was
another person with eyes that beautiful
right Hawkin what color are your
eyes uh I got the one brown eye you do
really oh wow that's that's bad you're
talking about your [__]
and two blue eyes that was good that was
good that one that one embarrassed you
right love yeah that was bad I can see
why that one embarrassed you but I
enjoyed
it I can definitely see why it would
embarrass you though so you have two
blues and one brown two Blues One
Brown same same color as the lava
actually same col I looked it up the
last time beautiful beautiful Blues yes
mhm that was
bad I'm not opening the mic for him
anymore that's enough what' you say love
no more mic privileges I'm turning it
off when damn you got recked wait they
don't have kids dude I got to see their
kids eye color I have to speak it's like
waiting for the new Prince to be born
you know like you know like when uh
Merkel and and uh the prince I don't
know what are the names Andrew had a
baby and like the whole world's watching
a new p is born that's what this is
going to be like we got to see their eye
color if they're brown it means that
there's Doom ahead of us that there's a
a cursed age for
us the talking
hawen love
it we love
it yeah well congratulations J shett on
winning the uh streamy award winning
live
mhm it's not fair that his eyes are that
color and he's got that much success
it's he does you don't get to have it
all Jay and you're in BMW ads when does
it stop
Gap mhm something terrible is brewing in
the in the shete Abode you can't keep
getting away with it yeah anyway we we
wish him the best yeah we do certainly
not bitter about it and certainly didn't
host an entire inli person show that
we'll do uh out of bitterness uh we're
doing a live show called The steamies at
the end of the year oh
W which unlike his which unlike streamy
will be
the sexiest night of the year for
YouTube and Santa Cruz in my own damn Fu
I I feel like I know where this is on on
Pacific right on my own damn stomping
grounds J shed's just there for what why
is he there what is he doing why is his
hand like that what is that supposed to
convey to me sincerity
trust love are is he doing a salute what
the [__] it says a lot to me actually
it's really speaking to me why does he
look he looks angry at me honesty
Integrity he looks angry that you
haven't bought Gap clothing yet honor
chivalry what's taking you so long by
that [__]
idiot yeah
he's
yeah all right I guess it's time we
probably there's so much I could talk
about there's so much fun that I could
have but but to be
real hold on no I got to hear a preview
of Cav Cav's podcast I I wanted to hear
this yesterday I have to hear it Ryan
kav started a podcast called failure
about all his failures thank you very um
it's a long show it's going to have a
lot of episodes such an interesting turn
in life
L it's like the Bible essentially nud
here here let's see so he he put out a
preview in my life I've been very
fortunate that I've had a ton of success
one of the common themes that is
prevalent whenever I succeed at
something is that I first fail and when
I look around it pretty much any
successful person around me the same is
true of them every no interesting just
you
dude I don't like the framing you're
doing Ryan because you were so much born
with a gold spoon and up your
ass the brown eye scooping the CH the
brown eye with your Golden
Spoon by the way Ryan this is fair use
[__] you see how I paused it and I'm
talking about it and I'm talking to you
and I'm adding commentary you [__]
[__] this is fair use try to sue me for
this this [__] thank you thank you for
the $60,000 you had to pay me for the
torous interference lost idiot thank you
Luke X every person prob be an episode
about
that one of his failures it should if
he's honest could be a whole season
you're him content goes through huge
failure in your life and it's that
failure that then leads you to the
motivation to the drive to take the next
step and to take the next step in
success and wow Ryan so novel I've never
heard that [__] before you got to
fail to succeed shut up Ryan you think
the first person to say that you made a
podcast just for that idiot nobody cares
I don't believe there's a successful
person who has made their own success
whether it's money or whether it's some
type of invention in a medical field or
in a Technology field or in the movie or
if you invented forest fire fighting
like me you invented the the LA Fire
Department business are INSP sports that
hasn't failed and failed and failed and
that's really what this is about and I
don't think anybody has really come out
and talked about failure we live oh my
God that is an insane statement I feel
like we get an iteration of the show
every month just because you didn't look
it up doesn't mean it doesn't exist and
you are so bad at everything you do and
this is a stark Stark example of it you
really you really came out here thinking
that this doesn't exist
I hope that he's actually going to talk
about failure though cuz he keeps
talking about like a lot of talk about
success yeah a lot of talk about success
for a podcast called failure you're
failing at making a podcast about
failing bro you're it should be called
failing up that is your life story by
the way you know what's funny he goes
I've never I've never seen a podcast
like this before look at this what we
found welcome to the Grateful atheist
podcast is the same
[__] it's the goddamn same graphic
wait a
second we were just talking about Gap oh
my god oh and it says Gap oh yeah Gap so
he's never seen this before
ever I I will say there's a a little
difference between the two the picture
is the same no the same picture if you
go to Ryan's yeah the hill is only
downhill it's only going downhill oh
wait oh which is kind of appropriate for
him I think he just cro he cropped it
differently but how weird wait I think
it's exactly the same it's just a diff
it's just
wider the the other one is a square yeah
yeah what a dumbass look at the person
it's like exactly the same it's the same
it is the same look at that
[__]
Ryan come on dude
in this Instagram Twitter Tik Tok world
where everything has to be perfect
everything is so pretty every story is
colored everything has I know you don't
believe in that just spend a [__]
minute on
triller
perfect you mean in
unoperated as
[__] lens of let me tell you how
wonderful everything is well you know
the truth is [__] sucks half the time
okay yeah let's start there's start
there yeah inspire me
[__] for all of us actually more than
half the time and it's getting through
those shitty moments and failing over
and over and over again that actually
lead to success and so as I talk to my
friends again all walks of
life producers directors actors pro
athletes billionaires businessmen
philanthropists phds inventors every one
of them their true success is a story of
failure people are so who's going to who
does he think's going to listen to this
man us anyway that's true we might be
the the only [__] does
it I've been I've been wondering about
this whole thing it's it strikes me as
so odd it feels like it feels like bait
but I don't know what the Trap Is Right
it feels like it's made for us I I know
exactly what you mean I agree with you
then I'm wondering what's the
angle B
that's an interesting I don't know
because like listen I'm I'm lawful as
[__] bro I'm lawed the [__] up but I'll
tell you this if you go if you if you
want to learn more because the podcast
isn't out yet hey Gabe hold on one sec
buddy I'm almost
done if you T go to Google and type Ryan
kavanau failure you can learn more about
this because it's not out yet if you go
if you type that into Google and click
on the top link the failure podcast that
camera
we have um done a nice little write up a
review frankly about the concept and
about okay our thought on the show so
right if you're interested go ahead and
type yeah Ryan Kavanagh uh failure
podcast in Google and
then you should see this article thank
you guys thank you so much for your
support hey
gabo hey where you going I miss you I
love you Budd fr miss you I love you I
miss you where are you
going uh we're going on a
journey a par where you a park Journey a
park Journey wild and
unknown yes huh which Park like the
Wilderness you going to the
forest Studio
City oh Studio City okay wow yeah this
rugged rugged Outback yeah I try to
avoid going out there man it's rough out
there uncivilized spooky it's spooky it
sure is spooked up nowhere it's crazy
out there in Studio City how you been
I'm good I'm working on my weight you've
been so good with that congrats you've
been so good happy for you man thanks
appreciate the love and support always
[__] [__] yeah [__] baby [__]
[__]
[__] [__] being fat [__]
[__] cuz I also lost weight pissing my
pissing my dick [__] pissing my
dick hole take my liposu my fat out and
throw it at your [__] dick [__]
[__] yeah pissing my pissing my
eyeballs
[__] lipo Su my fat out and use
it to cook a
steak
nasty I'm the meat Chef H I just I gross
myself out with that
one um
anyway
so I'll just go ahead and keep going
we're gonna do the um we're gonna do the
song tournament if you want to hang
around for that Gabe sure that song
tournament we could just cut to you
anytime if you want to stay on the
call wait yeah that's going to be like
hours Ethan well yeah you could you
don't have to stay going on an
adventure turn Adventure here we
go um by the way this is
actually now here's a podcast that I
think might have some legs
CED a
podcast there's three characters and
listen I'm not here
to all right three is a three A's
company three is a Three's Company
exactly knocking my waiting for you
yes yes yes yes
yes all right I'm doing it old
SCH oh and I also wanted to talk about
the document the documentary Wars that
is so [__] awesome I guess we can
wait we got to get to the segment it's
going to this tournament always
ever all right Gabe you can you can you
want to hang out you want to listen to
some dream remixes sure let's do it [__]
yeah baby [__] B [__] yeah [__] yeah um
so first before we begin I feel that
it's Paramount for us to acknowledge the
OG there was one Brave soldier that put
this out on a whim not thinking much of
it when I found this post it had a mere
hundred likes or something like that A
Modest a modest post MH and even now it
has only 600
underappreciated Jack Cronin 343 is the
father of this great
movement he is the person that made the
original remix that launched this whole
great
[Applause]
[Music]
thing I can't
so that is thanks to Jack Cronin love
him yeah and we acknowledge
Him for the uh for the Wooh Trailblazer
wo I can't do the woo I go
wo anyway thank you to
him also so listen we have 16
entries the crew was
meticulously
painstakingly going through all the
wonderful submissions you guys sent and
we love them all and we thank you all
for participating it breaks our heart to
have to pick only 16 right but we had to
do it one of the 16 actually got claimed
by
herself um unfortunately so we had to
exclude hers oh no should I say which
one it was just so she knows or just
make her feel
bad it might just make her feel bad
honestly it might make her feel bad I'll
listen to it if she can fix it like well
yeah we yeah we were hoping it would get
dropped uh before Showtime but it didn't
like during the show so I guess say it
if there's disco kid [__] is [__] yeah
you cannot get rid of the claims they do
there it's so messed up we did at some
point when we were setting this up try
and emphasize that that you will not be
included if if it's on something that
gets us claimed it's a bummer cuz it was
a good one it was a finalist part I feel
bad about is maybe she wasn't aware yeah
of because she those Services
distributed through the service I I'm
I'm absolutely certain that it was an
accident you know what I mean like
there's no way that she meant to do that
it's just the damn service well if you
think there's still time maybe say it
then well yeah I'll say what's the name
I don't have it in my doc what was her
name just sent it I just yeah oh this is
the song yeah I mean you can't play it
cuz it'll get claimed but I'll just play
you just show the uh what the post was
affectionate mix 166 hey I made this
hope it qualifies but this is my remix
song of dream I'll just play a second of
it no yeah you can try a second of
it it's muted on the Reddit player oh I
think I heard this one
actually no I haven't so that's so if
you can figure out how to remove that
then um we'll listen to it next next
week yeah gab your honorable mention
your thoughts on that Gabe well I don't
really know these kind of songs but I'm
listening and it's gonna be some new
songs I probably would just listen to my
first time so awesome
swe
woo so and because we' have lost one of
the finalists what we've done is our
beginning bracket we have five honorable
mentions okay the winner of this will
and I think the only way to do this is
playoff five okay and then vote between
those five because I don't want to draw
it out there's supposed to just be four
honorable mentions not nominated Al so
erase yeah I
mean just erase the one that that
doesn't belong there yeah I'll figure it
out so there's four so I'm going to play
all four of them remember remember which
ones you like cuz I'm not going to go
back on this one we got to keep it going
and we're going to vote on all four at
the same time so the first one this
one's uh for sure right the the Taylor
Watt
Dan I believe I'm checking right now
okay so out of these we pick one to
enter yes this one this one was for sure
in the honorable mention C so this one
will the winner of this will advance
into an the F into um the bracket the
bracket yeah into the
bracket all right right so this one
comes from
Taylor
Watt let's
[Music]
see I can't breathe you're not
there I can't sleep it's a night man
[Music]
I can't breath
you're I like it it's really a cool
artistic
[Music]
interpretation Ethan I gotta meet
somebody happy Friday happy Friday
thanks for hanging out with
us nice hanging with you buddy nice see
you the best Cheers I wish you all the
best man have a great weekend love you
bye have a good one
Cheers Cheers my dude cheers my dude
love you
cheers love
[Applause]
[Music]
you CLA Gabe everybody or no Uncle Gabe
excuse me
[Applause]
all so in in the interest of brevity I
feel like I've heard enough uh play for
just a few more seconds just so you see
where it goes because it does pick up in
a moment
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
okay all right so that's uh Taylor W I'm
just I'm I'm I'm going to try to zoom
through this cuz we have so much to get
to
guys reality taste of all these
honorable mentions this one is by
[Music]
reality me
oh what's up play love to see
you I like
this
[Music]
I all right that's that one there you go
pretty cool thank you to reality
flying fries de dream Beach here's the
third
one oh okay real quick I just say so we
we had a council yesterday as we were
picking all of these and uh and like a
grading system that we kind of narrowed
things down this was a highly divisive
one oh okay and and and therefore it
didn't make the cut but there were
several people I don't know if they W
care to identify themselves that that
were really pushing for this one this
one's important to me Zach was
advocating I mean he is the resident
musician and I get the sense Dan that
you are opposed to it I it listen all of
the ones that got what aren't you
opposed to no listen everything that got
to this stage was birthdays Dan hates
birthdays no no no everything that got
to this stage was already this was
already the cream of the crop so to
speak and then we had to narrow it down
and so it it wasn't my favorite no all
right let's hear it let's hear it
out
I can't breathe when you nothing oh yeah
he giving me
a no the dude
the Elliot
Smith I
[Music]
like fast when I feel like
that cuz I can't sleep it's a
nightmare
nightmare so is there more yep okay my
favorite part hasn't happened yet okay
you may want The Best Is Yet To Come you
want me to skip forward maybe skip
forward a little bit
I about to yeah was right it's always
like that it's always like that wait go
back go back go back oh a sack solo
there's a sack solo has little
[Music]
horn
woo
okay I've heard it thank you that's the
dream Beach I I would say
like I think I'm I like it but I'm
leaning more on Dan's side just in that
I don't think it's going to win the
tournament that was kind of my attitude
but there was there's True Believers in
dream Beach see El loves it wait till
you hear the the the ones in the bracket
are crazy well out of the four so far
yeah yeah yeah wow you're right you're
right you hate birthdays too huh you do
not put words in my mouth had enough of
that lately that one's still one of my
favorites like I would have voted for it
if it if we if you guys granted me the
pleasure of keeping it in I would have
voted for well they the people are the
ones granting the pleasure today okay uh
here is the final one I am
Sion and I love the Drake uh new song of
mine uh it's it's one of my favorite
songs I've ever made actually and it's
not it's not released yet so hopefully
at some point point it will
be you guys can sing along it's a lot of
fun to sing it's very uh it was a
written out a kind of tough time in my
life
for I don't want to explain it kind of
good
time you ready
go I can't breathe when you're not there
you're not there you're not there I
can't sleep it's a nightmare a nightmare
a night
I can't you're not there you're not
there you're not my head goes num my
heart fast when its feels
like o s
solo o with
[Music]
that I would like to finish this song
but I'm not going to this is going to be
that one was really good that one was
probably my that was really good so
let's go ahead and uh let's throw the
four up real wild card pick is going up
right now this is just to enter the
bracket to anybody that is confused yeah
for our last slot I'm trying to get
through it as fast that is why we didn't
listen to the whole song yeah we will We
Will We were just so many good ones we
wanted to find a way to incorporate some
of these cuz it was a shame to leave
them out Absol absolutely so this is
quite I personally thought IM Zion would
would oh it is winning wow it's so close
between I am Zion and dream Beach those
two are my
favorites both are so good yeah but now
Sion is
winning I think that's a dub for Scion
it's been a really dramatic poll well
let's lock it up and say congratulations
to wait hold on I'm going to leave it up
for one more second it's 42% man there's
not that many votes and uh I just want
to make sure all right I want to end it
before everybody sees that we're putting
up the poll you know what I mean okay
that's true there's a delay there's a
delay because of the
button audio is slightly delayed it does
seem to just be increasing over time
it's it's Gap though so we're up to
almost 6,000 votes yeah we can call that
we're call all righton congrats you
bumped up into the bracket
cion all right so we're moving C up and
with that being said let's get this show
started all
right welcome
everybody
to the first annual dream remix song
annual yeah oh yeah
annual we love tradition here on the H3
podcast yeah we
do um this is so fun dream blessed us he
released this song early and it blessed
our hearts and minds and it STG itself
right in our brains oh yeah and um it's
like it's with me every day this song
every day it's like a nightmare mhm it
is or a dream I mean or a
Dream well said not there and so we have
invited the community to bring forth
their best dream remixes the
winner of the tournament will be getting
an exclusive collaborative contract with
dream let's go with the there's an
asterisk I haven't asked him
yet I didn't ask you I think there's a
good chance
though um I'm seeing a bunch of people
saying they still didn't see the poll um
I mean the spread was good enough you
know what the poll is not there what do
you want what do you want from me it's
okay they're not mad are they mad at you
Dan no they're not mad they're just all
saying where's the
poll never saw the poll I don't know
what to tell you I mean lots of people a
l of V there was 5,000 votes and the
spread was wide enough that ifort
YouTube's polling is acting shitty today
so I I'll try using a an off site Poll
for the next one we might need to as we
uh well so anyway here's the first one
the Jersey Lawman he had a yeah he had
an entry is he at the top first bracket
the Jersey Lawman is a fixed year here
on the show he is an underground Jimmy
Lee meme account on Instagram and he's
super
talented do we know that it's the same
person or we don't know oh we don't know
interesting so here is dream nightmare
Remix by Ultra zany Edition well it is
it has to be the user is the Jersey
Lawman I could ask him it's
I saw him hyping it up on his it's got
to be him that's cool so anyway here's
his uh
submission it's
muted and this is once again zany
[Music]
Edition pull me out from the cage I've
known pull me up pull me up by the roots
we''ve
grown all the things you've SE
[Music]
okay I'm on the Dance
Floor no question about
it in Minecraft and out of
Minecraft my that
[Music]
I yeah we don't have to watch all of
it would let it go through
[Music]
thisis wait is this is this the fable
Jersey lmen is his face here is he
exposed his identity oh
perhaps might be Jimmy I think it's AI I
mean he's using an app but it looks like
a real person yeah I think he's using an
app to track his real face but it's kind
of right right right but no it does it
with this guy's face yeah you're right
it's
[Music]
not oh [__] there's a
breakdown
that Minecraft game is getting intense
too must be on a
[Music]
[Applause]
speedrun wait what the f that's going to
be a oler tree right what the [__] who
is this guy he's the goat he's the goat
dude what the
hell we've
grown all the things you said keep me in
my head I don't even know the could step
yours instead you're so close but I'm on
my own cuz I just don't know where you
go I can't Brea when you're not there
you're not there you're not there
I sleep it's a nightmare a nightmare
nightm
[Music]
I stop the contest
this so you're calling it already wow I
don't know if it gets better than that
bro I can't get over the Jersey llen is
this man delers incredible this was a
trip seeing Oliver in there yeah and it
actually works it works so well I think
cuz Oliver's music is like probably like
autotune trash anyway so it just works
well thei exactly you're coming in hot
technically he right you know you know
my dream is to dance in a European
nightclub in like 1998 and that just
made that dream come true wow specific
the thing is like I I would think that
it would be his body or something and
then he would track the face I don't
think the body is even real it's all Ai
and it's freaky cuz it also seems like
something that Oliver would wear you
know it's all very
trippy so do uh it's 5 minutes have I
heard
the oh I mean keep going as long as you
like Jeff is
involved chocolate tear my favorite
chocolate
Perfect all right in again in the
interest of brevity we have to move on
and we can give it a if it if it
continues on into the semi-finals we can
give the chance but we got a lot to get
through I think it might be time to
build a bridge to the Jersey lawmen I
need to know who this guy is we need
more
information like who are you exactly
mhm I think it's kind of I like the
Enigma behind it right you do I do like
it too I like it too but I got questions
but I like yeah I got questions who the
[__] are you
man anyway thank you Jersey lman a great
entry up next Smokey
quartz Smokey quartz nightmare beautiful
name oh this
[Music]
one I
when you're not there
oh it's like the do acid BR yeah
[Music]
nice I love
this yeah do I want to smoke Opium hard
almost like got jooy it's [__]
awesome so I like dream Beach earlier
this was another highly divisive one oh
this Olivia and I both this was like our
favorite and other people gave this a
one
oh you're either into this kind of
psyrock St or you're not so I mean at
least appreciate the Artistry of what
he's
achieved when it feels
[Music]
like the vocals go a little sou there
so that's it that was wow what a
treasure what a treat so that's already
strong first bracket as you guys were
saying some of PE of the crew's
favorites are up in the first bracket
going head to head right so let's throw
them up the Jersey law man for Smoky
courtz all right so I'm going to I'm I'm
going to use a straw pull this time um
instead of YouTube since apparently it's
having issues oh so I'm going to drop a
link in the chat right now and I'm going
to pin it please
everyone take this opportunity SP to in
the chat this is the poll for round one
it's between Jersey law man and smoky
[Music]
quartz and let's see there should be
some boats uh trickling in here an early
lead for the law man all right people oh
let me the results on
my on my page here I can throw it up on
my screen too if you like here I got it
oh my
goodness so there seems to be a
universal Acclaim for looks like it's
going to be a blowout people Jersey Law
Man Has It by 80 he's up 84% my goodness
you know what Dan I got to tell you we
get less votes doing it this way uh I
agree I'm noticing that as well there
let's just not do it this way then
well let's just see I mean some enough
people get it where you can get like a
good they call them dumps cuz like we
would have had like easily I mean I
guess it's similar maybe it's similar
people are saying can't but I feel like
we get five just they're [__] with
you they're [__] with you okay Dan
it's okay let's just do the integrated
one it's not your fault it work it'll
work fine all right
yeah although can I show that on SC how
do we show the integrated one screen
well I can not as easily no so maybe
this one's good for that reason it's not
your fault anyway Jersey La man wins by
a by a mile thankly well done sir
whoever you
are on to the next bracket we
have two friends
online
versus cter
Potter let's first listen to two friends
online I like the
[Music]
[Applause]
name you call me late at night cuz you
want to and I want to I understand
enough knowing that you'll come through
tell me where you be by my side of my
dreams
tonight I'm feeling empty when you're
not here it's like a nightmare I only
feel you when I'm dreaming and it's not
fair let me see when I'm is it giving
Kids Bops a little bit kids
bops Kids Bops it is giving a bit of a
Bop I was thinking like Blink 182 but
it's like the kids Bob's version of
Blink 182 100 gex dude yeah exactly it's
more this
is they're listening to kids this is
what this
what
[Music]
hyper it's true right all right I've
heard
true two friend and a lot of people in
our audience are loving it it's G oh for
did you they got chills we got the G
they got
chills I guess hey you guys should get a
kid I'm telling you zom out if you like
this you should get Kid Bops volume 83
that one's crazy they're listening to
that one goes so
[Applause]
hard but we've heard enough regardless
um we have so much to get to two friends
online I don't did you see the poll
results Jersey the Jersey lawmen
dominated okay yeah so that's two
friends online vers now cter
Potter
here we
[Music]
go oh the things you said Keep Me In My
Head wish that I could step into yours
instead you're so close but I'm on my
own cuz I just don't know where you go I
can't breath when you're not there
you're there you're not I sleep it's
night Nightmare
Night you're not there you're not there
you're not there my head goes home and
my heart beats fast when it feels like
[Music]
that
yes wait this is crazy this one goes
hard as [__] dream
standing he's dude dream is feeling
[Applause]
it in his
CS I love the instrumentals
[Music]
so I like that they SP it up a little
bit know that you
understand the things you said Keep Me
In My Head wish that I could step yours
instead you're so close but I'm on my
own cuz I just don't know where you go I
want to hear the chorus I can't breathe
when you're not there you're not there
you're not I can't sleep it's nightmare
a night nightmare nightmare I can't
you're not there you're not there
[Music]
[Applause]
you're oh
[__] okay I loved that that was so nice
that was a great that was just a great
track I kind of like how they mashed it
with his performance too it really feels
like it's him performance
me too I hope dream's watching all of
these I don't know if he is I know he's
he said he'll call in at the end at
4 um because I mean that's that's
fantastic um there it is let's put him
up head to head mono round two two
friends online versus CER cter cter
Potter cter Potter Potter I'm just doing
the YouTube one and if you don't see it
I'm I'm sorry but it is what it is we
are all so helplessly [__] by the way
for this weekend that this song is going
to haunt our I never want to hear this
again after today after yesterday and
now again
today well the votes are coming in Fast
and furiously um I'm not yet over it and
if anything I feel like these are just
making me like it more right now that's
exactly how I feel but I was embarrassed
to say no I'm in I'm so into it right
now I know there's going to be a crash
at some point where I'll be like I'm
done but right now it's still building
up for me this is The Melody of a
classic that's going to live in my so in
well the votes are in they're coming in
fast we got
5,000 and uh cter Potter has won by 75%
who apologies to Kids Bops volume 83 you
will have is the name two friends online
a lot of people loved yours so yeah um
everybody that made it into this is
awesome and made a great job yeah again
we we've listened to 100 plus yesterday
and so if you're if you're on this
bracket it was because we thought you
had something there I think generally it
was only included in spret if they
thought there's a chance you could win
right so it's the highest honor possible
really so congratulations cter C we got
two great submissions already next
bracket we've
got uh
JP versus d d bedo to DD bed toes d d
was thinking that sound
D so here's the first one this is by DJ
gamar wait what the [__] oh okay
featuring DJ G Nightmare in Dreamland by
JP so I was throwing a birthday party
for my brother everybody's drinking I go
in the backyard and everybody is [__]
what
I was walking
around and nobody wanted
[Music]
to I can't you're not there you're not
there you're not there my head goes my
heart feels like
that I like it so
funy it's so
funky solid
Baseline yeah I was living a baseline
too instrumentally it's like aage for
the
activity where's
ke
[Music]
that's okay I thought that was a fun
experience thank you J
sorry Keen if we missed your your cameo
all right up next is DD bed to DD Mega
dooo said Donkey Kong Vibes to that one
which yeah
definitely what bad Donkey Kong that
last song somebody in the chat I saw
said it has Donkey Kong uh you know the
Donkey Kong games like you agreed with
that you know about Donkey Kong games I
mean I feel like I've heard the DK rap
bro are you not familiar with the DK rap
I mean I was just surprised that Ela was
like oh yeah Donkey Kong yeah it's
Donkey Kong like I know what he means
okay DK I like DK DK I [__] with DK [__]
with DK hell yeah um I mean obviously
not the first iteration where he was
like basically stealing a woman against
her will which is a sexual crime yeah as
an act of violence [__] up [__] up
also was copyright infringement
King Kong King Kong yeah right um here
is the DD bed toes here we go one 2
three
[Applause]
4 loving the live music
[Music]
aspect this is a full rocket roll emble
right
here
[Music]
it was so short but a fantastic that was
good yeah I want more I know I want more
but we were just so impressed by the
effort for the full band and everything
I thought it was I loved it so much I
think as far as like live music goes
that would be a lot of fun to see I
would kill I
mean I love the the vocalist I wonder if
there's space on stage for both her and
Dream
well okay I mean you like it that much
that well I'm just thinking legit we
have eight more or you know five more
rounds or something just saying so let's
throw them up let's throw them up we got
J round three p versus DD Mega doodoo
bed
toes so did we order Taco Bell and
takaria yes we did I think so yeah mhm
and I I saw the last poll that people
were confused which is which it's always
going to be an order of appearance for
the poll yeah oh right got it
yeah so once again my friends we have JP
vers DD Mega doodoo bed
toes the votes are rolling in quickly
and
furiously thank you guys 5,000 votes are
in it's a 75 percenter for DD bed toes
hey the live the live the live one yeah
and I want to emphasize the first one
was really a phenomenal musical
expression yeah it had a Cool vibe yeah
you think they played the bass on that
or was synth Zach uh I think it was um
keyboard Basse yeah
yeah that'd be sick if they're playing
it I I love uh bass players who can
shred like that are crazy so regardless
very solid Baseline really good
yeah so okay very good moving on to the
next bracket thank you everybody thank
you so
much all right moving along having so
much fun aren't we I love this I mean I
mean what what a better way to spend
Friday we don't deserve it so much
talent the air we
don't Ethan play songs even time what do
that even mean even time I guess like
even
duration huh like if you give a song
let's say 2 minutes
then minutes to be fair yeah I I the way
I'm doing it is like I feel like if if
I'm about to IDE yeah if I'm about to
get to the second
verse I got the F you know what I mean
if it's starting to Loop and stuff yeah
which is fine for the structure of the
song but yeah we're just trying to get
through a lot of songs here so I
understand keep moving although I'll be
I'll be honest I don't think I think
this the way we're doing it is extremely
fair I don't think anyone's going to get
[__] over by this I think it will
still reflect the real results in the
world yeah I mean and us on the crew
listen to all of them in so if there's a
part that we feel like is coming up that
yeah we'll tell you step in some heat
there's some heat on the horizon oh man
but I'm having so much fun here I'm so
glad I came out today man man oh man man
oh man so up next is
Cardo versus uh one of those sleeper
ones that only had like three up votes
oh yeah yeah this one got like no
traction I can't believe that too and uh
you know that that happened during the
cavcav freestyles we we uh that's why we
learned our lesson some of the best ones
were the from space had like 20 up votes
on his yeah right right it's just that's
the that's the nature of Reddit I guess
it
just sometimes nobody's
online
um or they just haters in the new tab
right cardo versus I'm JC that's me so
cardo a dark sleeper all right and shout
out to the team who was able to you know
parse these
out nightmare nightmare nightmare I
can't breathe when you not there your
head goes num with my heart beat fast
and it feels like that
oh to say bro when you look at me like
that I get
nervous the baby you're
perfect and I sleep last that I next to
me
baby a
my but I don't need it I don't need
anything baby my
sustenance I write a about you and if no
one even so adding his own lyrics well
uh I think there's some of that and then
I think there's also some of the fact
that um we've never actually watched or
listen to the whole Dream song there's a
lot of other lyrics that they're drawing
upon uh I that's what I was wondering I
think I have heard all the lyc I don't
think these are new
lyrics yeah yeah I think they are yeah
he's made it his own guys a great
there's a few there's a few that do that
um but you know we'll still sample him
or I'm going to keep playing it cuz I'm
really enjoying it I wanted to clarify
that that's fine
baby what I'm
going I can't bre you're not there
you're not there you're not there I
can't sleep it's a nightmare nightmare
nightmare I bre not there your head goes
num with my hot beat SP and it feels
like that
oh oh oh you're not there you're not
there you're not
there it's a nightmare nightmare how
would you categorize this
song somebody said it Bill W yeah I
thought it Bill WS actually and I feel
like that's the category Olivia
mentioned Charlie po yesterday Charlie
poo yeah I F I loved that was really
that was so nice and it was so fresh it
was so different I yeah sounds just like
Charlie PU too is that what you're in
like a different beautiful one I but
yeah like the arrangement and everything
it it gave Charlie great by the way I
don't know anything about Charlie poof
but I dislike him only because I still
remember Dax to only I'm just you know
that's the only thing I know about I'm
opposed to I'm opposed still believe it
I I'm you know I can't let
go but wow that was phenomenal thank you
that was truly a sleeper card four up on
the sub right there that was fantastic
uh next up against this one is I'm JC
that's me okay JC that's
[Applause]
[Music]
me
is
[Music]
it's like a bad a trip
yeah good
one no but it's like it reminds me of my
badass it was this for 15 hours you're
like you're like I'm Li I'm here I'm not
here I
[Music]
exist
ooh
[Music]
oh oh that was
[Applause]
crazy I love your cat
yeah and I can tell you love your cat
too and I love that about
[Applause]
you
that's
[Music]
fun it feels like
that feels
[Music]
like
so um oh shout out gamer alert gamer
warning yeah look at that chair that a
is that a racer
dude is oh this this one is Prague May
what's it why does it say I'm JC that's
me no that's that's what they called it
instead of nightmare it's prag mare ohg
cuz this is like a prg
TG I thought it was fantastic yeah it's
cool really cool really artistic an
experience I never experienced before
yeah mixed meter music mixed meter so
that's Jazzy crazy Next Level [__] right
Zach Dynamic yeah like uh Froggy Stuff
tool does that a lot yeah really cool
really very cool yeah shout out to the
gamer you know what speaking of this
gamer
Alfredo is he's I feel like he's so
lonely and I've toyed with the idea of
getting him I don't I don't think I'm
ready to
like I'm not ready to move on I I know
it's not like that but in my mind
getting another dog is kind of like
moving on and I'm not I can't do that
mhm I don't think I'll ever be able to
get another dog for a long time so what
I was thinking is that maybe we could
get a kitten y
[Applause]
[__] I'll take my CL you bring that
you bring that little kitten in this is
news to me too I'm so down because I was
wondering we've been working on you for
years meow wow cuz if
I if Alfredo knows the kitten since it's
a baby I think they might I mean I'm
sure they get along but Alfredo hates
[__] cats I've had my family had cats
and dogs all through the years it's fine
like the you can totally socialize them
with each other and they'll get along
fine so I hope but I want a friend for
him so I don't know if they're if that's
going to be what it is the kids would be
so stoked about it the cat's going to
[__] them up though cuz they're they
don't know how to be gentle I mean they
they love it
though cuz our Nanny does fostering so
she brings cats a lot so and cats are a
lot easier than dogs right kittens first
puppies oh cat cats are infinitely less
maintenance to take care of than pittens
they like already know they're like come
potty trained they go from Factory
instantly yeah they like instinctually
know how to do it what the [__] dogs
where's your oh okay hold on hold
on you well you're defending all canines
Z yes I am um just saying it'd be nice I
uh I hate to interrupt the cat
discussion but I do need to draw your
attention this is by far the closest
poll that we've had uh it is neck and
neck between these
two
we are 248 it was
5149 make sure you vote matter there's
7,000 votes this is dump big massive
dumps of V big massive
dumps yes do you think Alfredo could
potentially having a cat would make him
less lonely or maybe he just needs a dog
companionship uh it's so hard to say it
depends on the cat and how open the cat
will be to playing with him and stuff
but um but again I I've I've had mixed
households uh so to speak pretty much my
entire life and I've had lots of dogs
and cats that like each other that play
with each other and stuff really I've
got a curve ball for you go ahead I
about a pig no okay we already don't you
remember I mentioned it and I got
freaking murdered in the comments you
guys will love having a cat they're
great they're great they the best great
I really miss my Shredder cuddles and
does with the cuddle oh my God I mean
that's the main reason to have a cat oh
they love cuddling I miss it so much
Shredder was like my cuddle buddy yeah
yeah I feel you Shredder could like read
our
minds yeah the time I miss him so much
but I think a cat could be um could be
an interesting
uh new thing to try that's it
thinking uh it looks like cardo I think
cardo is edging it out just barely but
uh 53% cardo after 9,000 votes I think
it's time that we can wrap it up call it
a day and
congratulate P congratulations very cool
prog we loved yours too though yeah that
was cool very I loved yours uh worth I
thought it was phenomenal so much fun
and Shout Out
gamer I know you're on the top I know
you're at the top top of the
scoreboard all right next
bracket Vampira
XOXO versus voluptuous
Apple okay up first
Apple all up first we're going to do
Vampira
XOXO let's take a
listen
I can't
breath
when I
[Music]
can't I can't breathe when you're not
there you're not there you're not there
I can't sleep it's a nightmare a
nightmare a nightmare I can't bre when
you're not there you're not there you're
not there my head goes numb and my heart
beats fast when it feels like that
[Music]
P love the vi
injection
[Music]
head goes and my heart beats fast when
it feels
like me into my dark and crew line I'm
only here to tell you all this one time
to be my might is you be my and of me
all the dam
time I always feel my heart be hurting
my chest I think I'm going at to
card this is an everyday reoccurrence
all the pain is now at this point I
genuinely don't know if that's her his
or hers lyrics right I have I don't know
makes it a good remix I don't know you
don't even know I think it's hers but I
I don't
know we refuse to listen to the normal
song I've I've done it once maybe but I
prefer not to I pr I prefer not to
Poison the Well yeah exactly
exactly I love it yeah it's really nice
I think she's great love
herance she's got a wonderful voice and
I love the confidence uh that she has to
you know get in front of the camera like
that you don't see a lot in the got a
cool
Loi aesthetic to it say what I said it's
got a cool aesthetic to it I like shot
it like that and everything yeah it's
just shot in the garage but it's really
captivating yeah I did notice there's no
Lamborghini in that
so it makes me wonder about her in myar
she doesn't know how to get a Lambo cash
but so that was vampire
XOXO really solid drum really solid drum
yeah that was one of my favorites love
her energy y I noticed also just to give
her a nod there was some Fanfare for her
in the um that was well I've been
looking at like like on Reddit it has
like it's got more likes than the other
on I saw and more views like 500 views
so there's some people who are uh
interested in the Vampira
XOXO
experience 500 present so here is
voluptuous Apple in
competition love the sweater that's
earning points right
[Music]
away
[Laughter]
[Music]
can't
[Applause]
me one more
[Music]
time
love the confidence Love The
[Applause]
Vibes love the
sweater sweater is huge for
me nice voluptuous
Apple thank you sir wonderful track
so up next in our next bracket we're
going to we're going to open the voting
Vampira
XOXO two by the way they both got on
camera and did their thing so that's
awesome I love to see it really do love
to see
it um that being said as much as I love
them both we have to pick a winner and
the votes are coming in they're they're
rolling in now 2500 but there's an early
lead for
Vampira uh a pretty commanding lead
actually 78% towards Vampira after 3,000
votes 79 now I think we could wrap this
up and call it a vamp 80% or so yeah wow
very
cool well
again thank you voluptuous Apple that
was that was really fun yeah I like
that all right next up we got little Tom
vers Shan Lorenzo
penzo so let us begin with little
[Music]
Tom I love
DJ dude that was what you guys think
that guys want to learn it together shut
up [__] what
[Applause]
a dam son damn ready
go oh
[__] oh oh my god when you're not there
you're not there you're not there I
can't sleep it's a nightmare a nightmare
a nightmare I can't you
there you're not there you're not there
my head goes my
hearts okay you didn't have to go that
hard
yes
damn
uh-oh
wow what you think of the shredding Zach
phenomenal really absolutely phenomenal
that was
amazing nice little Tom my goodness Tom
that was that was a lot of fun yeah the
violence towards dream threw me off when
it happened I think I think on your dad
I want to disavow that
yeah um that being said cuz I love the
video too the whole edit was really fun
yes wow wow wow wow little Tom okay up
next Sean Lorenzo penzo you got a big
task ahead of you yeah let's see if
you're up to
it um oh man I see a a cello is that a
standing base or a
cello that'd be a cello that is a
CH oh my god oh hell
yeah
sounds so weirdly appropriate in this
style like it
works he's so good at it [__] wonderful
your finger got to be crazy
strong
somebody said variations on nightmare
yeah uh a really beautiful display of
wow I felt like I could see a scene of
like the the uh the father and husband
returning home after a long War it's
like odys Odysseus arriving back uh from
his Odyssey so we're going to take a
brief respit here AA if you will yes
right and um we're g to see we're going
to check back in with love and
Hawkin who has never I I should do the
poll for that last round though before
while it's still fresh in our yeah
people can start voting all right here
we go now you never had a taco like this
like a Mexican
taco so this is fast food this is like
not authentic yeah I'm going to give him
one of the tig oh okay that's one for me
okay so we don't have any hot sauce yet
but no hot sauce not yet what did you
give him love I gave him a what's it
called Dorito she's
freaking attack of supreme love love is
crazy about this stuff but this is
without cheese and tomato cuz I don't
like it did we get something did we not
get something for hins we did but he
wanted the official like the authentic
place the authentic place is almost here
yeah he got a like a aada burrito oh wow
from the other place did you get a shupa
loopa
no what do you think this one it's kind
of me it's kind of
me isn't no uh
no spice no spice sauce on there
literally a it's it's a Dorito shell
love is big on sauce where's the sauce
maybe it runs in the
sauce well this is chalula it's
technically not it doesn't like Chala
you think it's dry I can see what you
mean it being maybe dry I know you guys
like your gravies and stuff yeah we love
Sal yeah you guys are a saucy Bunch oh
yeah Saucy boys so dry maybe is the
commentary because real so Mexican food
usually dump salsa on it so we'll
probably do that when the other one
comes I think it was sort of lacking in
flavor lacking in flavor yeah hold on
one second we're having a little bit of
a issue here with the camera the Dorito
shell
GL oh he doesn't like that well I got
got him the Dorito cheese flavor shell
which is surprising that should taste a
lot no but there's no there's no Sals in
there which is like a good part of it
just SL some Diablo salce in there
that's how I like it m yeah there's no
salce at all no no and that's
yeah I thought we got him something else
yeah yeah he got a a s burrito I think
it's going to like it the burrito I'm
very interested on what you're going to
think about that
yeah okay mhm that'll be here soon
destroyed that [__] Taco destroyed
that [__] that taco never had a chance
do it against
me all right how we doing on the uh
voting well uh it's at about 8,000 votes
and uh it was pretty close actually but
little Tom the first one uh with the
guitar uh is winning with 59% to 41% for
uh Shawn there with the cello so put up
an aboral fight there Sean it was really
close that
that's congratulations little Tom thank
you for the
Artistry uh to Shan Lorenzo
penzo with that being said it is time to
move on to the next bracket here today
on the H3
podcast dream the annual dream remix
Edition how's everyone doing out there
hope everyone's having a good day is
looking
clear Sunny light Breeze coming in the
Northeast all right up next bro why you
tooting
me it's no Slam at
you who is it at then it's no slam it's
add Ambience
Vibe it's just Good Vibes dude Good
Vibes it's a too isn't that the sound
that's like what you make when someone's
like fail f that's like a f sound well I
did not mean
[Music]
that all right Georgio Peterson versus
Riptide H like the Simplicity of the
name but up first this is
Georgio
Peterson now this one was very important
to one of us and you guys could guess
this this one means a lot to somebody on
the crew I'll let you decide it is how
do you know that was it written
explicitly in the submiss there's
there's some Clues throughout oh oh it's
very subtle but you pick up on it okay
interesting okay interesting I'm going
to go back to the beginning I Don't Want
to Miss a
moment
[Music]
[Applause]
wa I can't sleep when you're not there I
think about you all the time you're
always in my hair my head I said it
wrong again I'm stuck inside a dream but
I don't want it to I'm watching waiting
you're in my dreams I'll take your hand
tonight but I know that it's all in my
head oh oh oh Olivia let's start
again do you know this guy or
no no okay not yet want to make sure I
just want to say I I this guy always
comes to my shows and he's he's the
nicest [__] He's local yeah he he's
the there's a connect interesting he's a
local Georgio Peterson he he's he's a
great dude he's a bit of a hunk I'll say
it and he seems to have a car I've been
I've been hearing that lately he has a
he has a car girl true girl so true
that's
all I want to hear what else he's got to
say let's
[Music]
see I can't bre when you're not there
I can't breathe when you're not there I
can't sleep it's a nightmare let's take
it back to our very first day I picked
you up and you said you like my car I
said I like your eyes and then you touch
my thigh my mind is breaking into pieces
but I just I can't stop thinking my
heart beating your lips so sweet
tonight but I know that it's all in my
head oh oh oh
let's start
again hold on is this have anything to
do with the actual task at hand what am
I listening to I think it's
great does this is
this related at all
yeah I I think he used the word dream
once or twice I mean it's called
nightmare word nightmare maybe yeah no
he said it was a nightmare I guess that
works listen it's an Artis
interpretation mhm I don't know about
that I mean obviously we love the
subject matter yeah thank you we we love
the subject and I'm to let it be in the
competition however if this was a
homework assignment I would
definitely leave a note about it not
being related to the assignment he's he
he's the nicest [__] guy too I have
to say he's a really good dude he shot
his shot though look at this he got me
to play
it
I
can't do you know do you know if that's
his car or is it potentially his mom's
car do you
know me yeah I did not know you never
saw his whip I never saw his car
no I'm not trying to dash your dreams of
him owning a car Olivia I'm just trying
to scope him out no I love I love that
we're being a realist about this yeah
yeah yeah I think he has his own car
though I think so too it seems the data
is pointing towards he owns a vehicle so
h yeah so hot dude I love when guys have
cars it's so
hot
there I can't Brea when you're not there
I can't sleep it's a nightm I can't
sleep it's a
nightmare he's there I
amular
okay I am
rectangular
I feel it my this is giving Third Eye
Blind you know I love
that oh Olivia let's start
again oh oh oh oliv let's start
again well there it is um your if you
have a response I don't know you hello
that's my response hi I'm here I'm here
we'll talk later
chario the
song and Giorgio if you do message her
just include the registration on the
car oh I need to I'm going to need to
know vehicle history yeah yeah
exactly oh that was fun unexpected uh
treat that was um Georgio Peterson he's
up against Riptide okay Riptide is
Legend he's the one who submitted our
Halloween themed music in the past for
Halloween episode
oh very interesting so here it is by rip
tide and I love the name I mean it's
right to the point you know this one has
a lot of views 800 views 84 likes
Something Happening
[Music]
Here TI in the Jack cuz the weight
screen long the queen he can do no right
I at home making songs to confiding man
the man your million miles apart but
when
dance I don't give a [__] long as I with
you
I nice
[Music]
zeld that dog looks like it should be
small but it looks big
yeah there you're not there you're not
head go my hearts it feels like
that my heart I P time
or I back to the and fall in love with
you I can't breath when you're not there
I Brea when you're not there head voice
thank you man I was losing
attention I was about to pause
[Music]
it those are pretty
colors wow RI TI a really
tremendous this is an interesting
bracket uh ladies and gentlemen yeah
we've got Georgio Peterson in a a love
OD to uh Olivia m
and also we have Rip Tide who is a
frequent contributor and a mega Talent
here on uh on the show is Alfredo trying
to go potty I think he's looking for
food trying to eat something cuz he's
smelling everybody's
food sorry
Freddy I wish I could share it with you
man it's Taco Bell
dude that meat has got a lot of salt
MH well very good let's let's go uh turn
to the uh the voting I don't know who to
vote for
H well did you like the good one or the
bad
one did you like the good one or the bad
one I like the good
one I'm just kidding
Olivia oh so I know what I know what you
meant now I know which one you think was
the bad one no
[Music]
no well AB the audience agrees with you
oh two friends online said something
thanks for having us on the show did
nobody see
this uh thank you uh two friends online
for your wonderful submission uh thank
you it was wonderful appreciate you I
love you for that absolutely tremendous
love you so uh AB the audience agrees
with you Georgio Peterson he was a
little off task But ultimately delivered
he may have not won the contest but he
may have won the heart of a certain
somebody same as possible he was great I
just I'm I'm bi I like Rip Tide a lot so
but rip tide is definitely taking the
Dub here with
70% that is a clean clean win for him
nice so moving on the next
[Music]
bracket
um okay this is the oh my God bees from
space yep oh my god the guy that won
okay won the um Ryan kavan
or no it was the green screen one that
he blew us all out right it was the yeah
the an nuke green screen song he did the
anook it was the green screen
competition and he made this song that
changed the world as we know it
seriously I am a huge I can't believe
beast from space is in this you
guys holy
[__] it's not even fair to the other
people he said turn it up
Zach the
words my
hand in other
words kiss
[Music]
me the music the visual was nuts go put
your hands on put your hands up I'm not
going to ask you
again all right cut it so this is
exciting bees from space is uh up
against our Dark Horse entry okay which
I'm can someone put that down there in
16 please meanwhile let's take a look at
bees oh this is exciting
Me Maybe maybe my expectations are too
high though I don't know because I I am
a huge fan of his work we'll
see I can't bre when you're not
there
[Music]
there I can't SLE it's a nightm what the
[__] straight
[Music]
up you're not
there you're not there not
there there head goes and my heart beats
fast when it feels like
that
[Music]
[Applause]
I can't bring when you're not
[Music]
there I can't it's nightm I I get the
feeling like he's playing those
instruments like that basine oh
absolutely he's a Class Act professional
holy and that is a [__] George
Harrison esque solo if I've ever heard
that's it I mean like this guy is
shreding
[Music]
dude it feels
like you're not
[Music]
there you're not there
[Applause]
[Music]
St in my heart fast when it feels like
that
[Applause]
it's also like very I mean it's very
classic rock very Pink Floyd very it's
it's psychedelic it's it's rock and roll
little King Crimson in there it's a
little wow I mean what a talent holy
[__] man I wish that I could see him um
play some the stuff
right damn beast from space is nuts yeah
um you say it's very divisive on this
one
e yeah I see a lot of
um reaction I can see why in the sense
that it's a
little he does stuff with the vocals
that are more Avant guard than than
other ones you know what I experimental
yeah it's more experimental apprciate
that mhm um is this a new Boogie video
it got worse the wait is this part two
the continual fall of Boogie hold on did
I see this one Boogie oh yeah I think I
did [__] two hours documentary about
Boogie I guarantee that guy whoever that
was I don't know they probably have 10
video essays about me probably
too
um yeah wow oh interestingly Riptide had
sent a comment earlier they said
submitted a song and I'm dying every
announcement Ethan gets distracted I
love you fer chuper so talented Rip
Tide you're
in you're in and you've Advanced oh hold
on the burrito has landed
so um it's opening right now so hawen
now this is a a
burrito just just to to um address the
Taco Bell stuff those were lfi they were
lfi yeah so they were strips so you
don't you didn't get a fair I I I can't
I can't give a fair assessment because
that's fair does that mean no cheese or
there were there were no lot of NOS yeah
nothing no sheese no tomato us
tomato I think I missed the the red
stuff do we not have a taco supreme or
something
extra okay but anyway you've got a
takarita burrito so what I recommend is
take a take a few bites without salsa
and then go in for the salsa bites as
well I don't know you know the quality
really varies from one place to another
mhm is this your first time having a
burrito right you have food in your
mouth you could just
nod Ethan doesn't care about that he'll
he'll talk for
hours you he's the one that talks with
his mou I understand you're being polite
I don't that's not how we do it around
that's not how we roll
yeah I mean this one has flavors yes
okay we like flavors there we go all
different flavors this is your first
burrito all different flavors yep
interesting oo this is big you like
spicy too this is big oh this one is not
spicy spicy in this one so again the
takarita takarita varies so much in
terms of
spicy and uh quality it's
[Music]
like what where do we get this from Sam
or don't say right we don't or is this a
place we usually order from there's a
new spot
oh
[Music]
okay you did the Sals it's
pinches
Pines they're
like wait this is
chicken I moved down from the bre corner
and got into the meat pieces and I mean
it's uh spicy spicier so wait what yeah
this one's good really good this is
chicken the St I don't know she
said Sam what did you say um there's
three chicken in your box but two of
them are like a different style oh okay
and which one is yours and then Hil has
one fish in there as
well okay D I love corn just [__] yeah
baby just hitting corn oh you just
hitting corn Mexicans do corn pretty
pretty good they don't [__] around with
it so um you're gotten to the middle of
the burrito have you added salsa to the
bites yet I I'm taking one of these
[Music]
uh
triangular stuff salsa or chip tortilla
chip tortilla chip okay
no m m I say it's the same name for in
Swedish totila chips it's it's not a
potato chip totila
TOA
yeah so I see other people being
confused about that name too in the chat
and I looked it up that is the name of
the
place PES is like it's like a curse word
in Spanish that's why I was like
confused when you were saying it was
called P
tacos what does it mean I think it like
roughly it's just kind of like a
exploitive that it's like something
sucks or is a piece of [__] kind of
thing like so they're like our food
sucks it's kind of funny yeah yeah
that's what it's called um I would
recommend trying the red salsa have you
tried dunking that in just oh no not
that one C can you get him a red
salsa red salsa coming up coming
up I do have to say this one from Taco
Bell
oh that one oh that's the jalapeno sauce
that hits that's that's that's that's
good stuff that's a jalapeno ship that
that's the bus and bus and dip yeah
that's that's
excellent is there another red salsa
[Music]
guys salce is good yeah people yeah uh
it's like a mo it's like calling
something that [__] sucks like why
would you name the rest that that is
insane it's like name a podcast failure
yeah
yeah yeah it's like it's like their
places called [__] tacos for Haw
these [__] tacos I'll take one though
no I'm I'll take one oh yeah real
Mexican food by real Mexican go all
right so this is the red salsa it's a
little
spicy okay he wants the spiciest one
no oh what the [__] let me see which one
you have is it the dark yeah that's all
this one's like pink like what the [__]
is this I don't know what that sometimes
there's like pink salsa and it's deadly
spicy I have a feeling this is death
deadly
spicy so dump it in there you want to be
pretty generous
[Music]
there it's kind of interesting actually
you might like this one oh my God it's
making a mess it's
okay embrace the process
it's just
smoking smoking just barbecue the salsa
is just
Smokey sort
of bit did you pour enough take this I
do it like
[Music]
this there we go another more more more
more there you go
now you get to now you
[Music]
understand Hawkin is
devouring let me see the inside I want
to see
what yeah that looks pretty respectable
of Freedom feeling
no that that was a bit strong that was
okay all right there you go you bad
Mexican food welcome welcome to thank
you
welcome C great place to visit remember
that
[Music]
song like bigest
Smalls
mhm all
right he's breathing a bit heavier now I
think it's
spicy I'm feeling it more now yeah I
will start to become shiny in the
forehead and perhaps on the nose you
know Mexican food's pretty tricky like
some places the spice they get it right
or it's mild I don't right it's
everyone's preference but sometimes like
the salsa is so [__]
spicy and sometimes it's not spicy at
all I mean do we need we needed some
kind of Collective Agreement on
this you know we need to bring the
takaria families together
that's
I brought you all here
today the great the five Great
families to discuss the level of spice
in our
salsa it's come to my attention that
some of the salsa is just too spicy for
most
people I took my grandmother out for a
taco she [__] for two days it's not
right poor Nana all right let's do
another uh so beast from space fantastic
up next is the honorable mention win I
am Zion z which was the so here we'll
listen to this one
now here it is uh it's it's one of my
favorite songs ever made actually and
it's not it's not released yet so
hope'll play at some point it will
be you guys can sing along it's a lot of
fun to sing it's very uh it was a
written out a kind of tough time in my
life
where I I don't want to explain it kind
of a
time you
ready this one spicy
FR night I like this
one thees are right head num my hearts
fast when it feel feels like that
[Music]
attack you guys feel like you got a
handle on the
lyrics Let's see
[Music]
it I can't breathe when you're not there
you're not there you're not there I
can't sleep it's a nightmare a nightmare
a nightmare I can't bre you're not there
you're not there you're not my head goes
numb and my heart beats fast when it
feels like
[Music]
that I love this one The Vibes are so
good dreams vocals featured
prominently beautifully dreams sounds
great on the
track the track sounds great on
[Music]
dream wow wow better I I got to say
better than I remembered actually that
synth goes hard dude it it really
does so this is a big one guys I don't
know where to take this but it's up to
y'all bees from space previous winner uh
extraordinarily talented musician my
goodness who are
you up against I am Zion the Dark
Horse coming in from the honorable
mentions will he make it to the next
bracket you've got
[Music]
basically you got classic rock firsts
the
new you know how would you describe this
how would you how would you place this
song
one I guess it's kind of like new age
raw maybe I don't know yeah new age I
don't think that's generally like a
contemporary well adult contemporary
yeah kind of like Dave Matthews
ban
um
adult well the voters have uh voiced
their
opinions and at home you all have said
after 5,000 votes 86 87% I am Zion bees
in space I think bees in space if I
may I think you you just took it a
little off on guard mhm the fact that
you did are not winning this is because
the world has hasn't caught up to you
yet
but um it was really cool and I think
you took a risk and sometimes M you know
sometimes it's just not going to
resonate with everybody but can see that
you tried something really cool
and it did work it's just uh it's on on
guard it's a little guard you know what
it's the bleeding edge of music you know
it's like
listen it's good but sometimes it cuts
deep
so congratulations to uh I am Zion the
Dark
Horse Zion Zion I am
Sion I I am
rectangular am
rectangular ah so that put us through
our first uh our first round let take a
look take a look at the bracket out a
little bit uh Mr
love
there you
[Music]
go so we are uh hitting a quarter finals
with uh the Jersey law man cter poter DD
btoes card Vampira XOXO Littleton
Riptide and I am cion congratulations to
you all huge huge submission um I also
wanted to shout out there was a super
chat a little bit ago uh from a $100
donation from two friends on line which
was the um the sort of 100 gcks geeky
one here I'll put this one back up just
saying uh thanks for having us on the
show you're welcome nice it was this one
thank you thank you was that the kidsbop
one I was it was the one that you called
kidsbop yeah but it's because you're a
boomer that you would call it that I'm
sorry Dan say say that again to my
[__] face Dan hates birthdays Dan
hates birthdays Dan hates birth get out
of here with that Zach out of here you
think that because I'm quote Old okay 3
am I 38 uhu oh there goes his memory
42 what2 I heard you this time I heard
you maybe if I wasn't being gaslit cons
on a daily basis by my [__] crew yeah
I would actually so confused how old I
am it is mean it's mean to uh
intentionally try and confuse
an what year were you Born Again In Dan
again oh you're what 8 years older than
me uh no what was your birth year like
this same isn't it you're like 86 no I'm
like I'm 93 [__] Dan is [__]
throwing Jimmy from a glass house I'm 80
uh 87 is my birday 87 yeah I'm in from
85 I'm a 9 kid like Jimmy Lee so let's
take it easy over
there old ass all right let's move on to
the final bracket guys or not final but
let's move on to the next stage of this
tournament so pull
up okay
so the Jersey Law Men is back all right
fan favorite against another fantastic
one couter Potter cter Potter so this is
the first semifinal bracket here let get
so difficult let's look and listen to
the Jersey law man which was
this
yes pull me up pull me up by the roots
we've
grown oh all the things you've said Keep
Me In My Head wish that I could step
into yours instead you are so close but
I'm on my own cuz I just don't know
where you
go me in
and this is dely this is
[Music]
dream I'm also thinking like which one
of these is dream going to want to
actually do a collab
with this one I can see yeah this has
potential I can see this is a
bide although I don't know what Oliver
tree would have to say about that this
might be too good what does thatan it
might be too good this it is too
good what do you guys mean by that it's
a bob I'm not saying it's better than
the original of course I would never
said that I'll say it well this is of
remixes often times are I mean to be
fair he even said that yours is better
than mine when he called
in and he was talking about the OG
one I don't think he even I think he can
forget about the original track and this
is the
song right it's still crazy to me that
we talked about going to that
concert yeah and then this is what came
of it yeah we did yeah we were we saw
that he was playing a concert in LA and
we were like should we go to the dream
concert we could have been there for
history I know it was like that day and
we're like oh it's it too
[Music]
late you would have been spotted and
eaten alive like
piranhas in the audience I don't think
his ban knows any of those
[Music]
yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
is what the
hell this song is like genre bending
too why who is this
jersey
he's so
multi-talented all is this [__] who's
this Michelangelo I mean Jesus Christ
Benjamin
Franklin you even got Mark in there yeah
Jeff Jeff
Jeff I
can't heart
half that I can't see you're not there
you're not there you're not
[Music]
there
nightm night
night oh it's pretty long I guess uh I
guess that's it right oh yeah that's the
one keep changing
genres let me go let me sneak to the
back and see
[Music]
if oh there's a
solo I can't break when you're not there
you're there you're not I can't sleep
it's a nightmare a nightmare a nightmare
I can't bring when you're not there
looking up there that my heades num and
my heart beats fast when it feels like
that
whoa who is who is this guy what the
[__] there's no way this guy also shreds
the guitar on top of all there might be
collaborators on this
maybe what the
[__] that is sounds just like [__]
like a Marty fredman Mega Death solo
dude like it's this guy is [__]
talented as sh who how can he how can I
don't know what's going on with this guy
man I think if him and Beast from space
uh met up there' be a black ho would
form that' be crazy the universe would
collapse I think you're right from when
I played with like U deep faking myself
on the show I think that is his face
under those faces I think he's singing
the song and um putting their face on
hiss like cuz I recognize kind of how it
looks and that's kind of how it looked
when I did it for the show mhm so I
think he that's his face below there
which is pretty fun I don't know dude
because it's so much just Dreams yeah
see I don't I can't tell of his dreams
or else it's dreams but it's also
somebody else's face but he's not
getting any of the words
right in there like he isn't really
mouthing the words it's off a little bit
the way if he was doing it yeah it's
delayed slightly I
think you're right but those aren't is
that him right if that was him is that
you Jersey law man are you in
there trying to see his soul Jersey law
man is that
you I'm so some people are saying it's
like he made five songs too I'm ABS it's
so
long
got twists and turns Enchanted so that's
H sheez the Jersey law man is crazy
Juggernaut I'm definitely really
captured by that one that's
solo captivated unbelievable the word it
is so I think it must be a collaborate
there's no way he's that good at all
this stuff you can't be good at video
editing making music and shredding the
guitar he's a class should we try to
reach out like during the the show I
want I need to know who he
is well I don't know I mean yeah right
now who are you man I like the Enigma
though dude that's the other thing right
the enma you like what I didn't hear the
Enigma there's something romantic about
it but maybe he's like maybe the Jersey
law man is like
um Ringo Star or something like some big
uh you know who else who else could do
what else Paul McCartney probably is
yeah it must be all right up next by the
way when we hear like a guitar solo
could that be made by AI or do you guys
think that I know I I have heard some
solos made by
AI um I I don't know if his is I don't
think it is it sounded way too like on
it sounds way too good it was really
tuned in there man but again that's kind
of his thing like he is this Anonymous
dude that is always using AI he's very
capable his one skill this would make
more sense his one skill is AI is that
he's a computer he's a hacker you know
what if he was just a computer it's not
even real it's just a chat gbt for my
best friend if that Solo's AI then I
give up on guitar I'll quit I agree
that's [__] up that's not fair at all
we have so many questions oh he said
he'll call in all right
let's oh man let's you want to keep
going yes please we still got so much to
do it's 4:30 yeah we still oh it's 4:30
yeah all right so up against cter Potter
uh here we go cter Potter
verse Jersey law
man pull up pull up by the ro oh yeah I
really like this one too the you keep in
my I could step into yours instead
you're so close but I'm on my own cuz I
just don't know where you go no I can't
breathe when you're not there you're not
there you're not there I can't sleep
it's a
nightm IED It
Up live
audience feel like
[Music]
that boom dream break it down brother
show excitement I love that part is a
rockar dude get it this is your moment
man [__]
yeah that's rock and roll just standing
there rock and roll dude Feel The Beat
brother let the music Move
you call me in call me in if you take my
hand oh baby that's how know that you
understand oh the things you said Keep
Me In My Head wish that I could step
your said you're so close but I'm on my
own cuz I just don't know where you go I
can't breathe when you're not there
you're not there not I can't sleep it's
a nightm night nightm can't you're not
there you're not there you're not my
head goes and my heart be when it feels
like
[Music]
[Applause]
that
uh-oh go dream
[__] go look at this front man
energy is that Mick Jagger holy [__]
dude explosive
energy M Jagger wishes yeah just to be
just I'm being silly because his trap
obviously sounded
different just being
[Music]
Sil man both of these are so good all
right let's throw it up Dan all right
throw it I don't know which one I would
vote for well you've got the Jersey law
man and co uh cter
po this is my vote Ela but it's really
close I think that's mine too
yeah well I got to say Jersey law man
whoever you are you're advancing to the
next round crazy
76% say the Jersey law man it is his
time this is the moment where the you
know just like dream The Mask comes off
who is he right oh my God I know I know
it I know it all right let's move it
along we please take off your mask we'
got uh DD bed toes versus
cardano okay the live music which we
love love love I got to go back cuz they
shred at the top yeah 1 2 3 4 you can't
Brea when you're not
[Music]
there you're I do love this like
uh gr Rock I love this
music it's so real so [__] real it's
[Music]
so
wow I love that
one love them we need more I could
slowly see them going on tour with dream
you know I'm sure it's going to happen
which for sure it's going to happen yeah
so that's DD bed toes vers and now card
card let's take a
listen oh yes this one is
spicy I can't see the Nightmare Night
nightmare I can't Brea when you're not
there your head goes num with my heart
beat and it feels like that
[Music]
oh whoever is doing the vocals is kind
of crazy like the guy and the girl seem
like professional s they're kind of
crushing it on that a guy and a girl you
guys I think it's huh I'm not kidding I
think it's Charlie po you think Charlie
poth entered as yeah as honly card cardo
I think so I think this is him
probably right I love this photo no it's
Charlie
blue I'm going to keep playing but I
just had to PA unated like dude the
vocals are nuts they're really the baby
you're
[Music]
perfect next to
baby my there
definitely but I don't need c dude I
don't need anything baby
my I can write a book about and if no
even ever it oh baby that's fine baby
I'll this is a
fuing
can't I want to see them per live
[Music]
also the the music is super [__]
interesting Bruno Mars is crying right
now Sam
Smith Sam Sam I Am Sam you are's Sam
true just to go back
to just to play this uh the women's
vocal
here I think it's him you think he does
both it could be pitched yeah hold on
let me let me
hear night nightm nightm
[Music]
I your head goes numb with my heart
beats and it feels like that
[Music]
oh bro that's crazy definitely could be
one person the
harmonies going on
there that song is crazy dude oh my God
yeah there's so much going on in so that
was uh and that was the one that had
three points right on the subreddit yeah
yeah it it had like three or four I
think holy [__] so let's throw it up
it's DD bed toes the
live versus cardo Bruno Mars uh uh
Billboard top Next Top musician what the
[__] that was crazy produced the
production was very very good very
impressive I'll listen to that in the
car right good for
real bro I want I want to make music
with you guys I don't even care what I
do or what I say it'll sound [__]
awesome these are the kind of people I
need to make music with well to blow out
T because um it's a tough competition
the other one just had so much so much
character yeah so much
character it's a shame to see him go mhm
but they really went up against such a
juggernaut DD bed toes I love you guys
keep going man keep going keep [__]
jamming my dudes I wish it was longer I
wanted more I you can tell they're young
dude kids having fun I mean keep slay
it's a badass [__] garage band right
there yeah hell yeah it is I love you
Zach Zach Zach is so real for
that Zach is I love it some say the
realest
some I love when you do that
too um so cardama wins with 67% wow
that's that's a heavy heavy entry all
right up next we got vampire XOXO versus
little Tom little Tom so here's vampire
XOXO uh everybody's
favorite little
[Music]
devil it's it says it says vampire she's
a little
devil
weird you little
[Laughter]
[Music]
devil I
can't
[Music]
I I can't breathe when you're not there
you're not there you're not there I
can't sleep it's a nightmare a nightmare
a nightmare I can't breathe when you're
not there you're not there you're not
there head goes num my heart beats fast
when it feels like that
[Applause]
p p p p p p
p p p p
p My head goes my heart beats fast when
I
feel attack come follow me into my dark
cre line I'm only here to tell you all
this one time to be my mind is to be my
enemy all the D
time I always feel my heart be hurting
my chest I think I'm going at to card
rest this is an everyday
reoccurrence a pain is
mine that layering is
beautiful I can't bre when you're not
there you're not there you're not there
I can't sleep it's a nightmare a
nightmare a nightmare I can't
wa not there you're not there you're not
there my head goes down my heart beats F
when it feels
like P
[Music]
attack
we love her we love the energy yes we
love the
vocals we love the talent on display
cool little
Tom good luck not little Tom oh you're
wishing little Tom Good Luck Good Luck
little Tom I got you she got lots of
love um in the chat too she's she's
great andir XOXO love love love the
energy so there you go up next is little
Tom let's see who will R
green oh
[Music]
[Applause]
this what do you guys think of that one
you guys want to learn it shut up
[Applause]
[__] damn
[Music]
son those dancing dogs go way too hard
actually can't bre when you're not there
you're not there you're not there I
can't sleep it's a nightmare a nightmare
a nightmare I can't
you're not
there you're not there you're not there
my head goes my heart oh
wow
the
uhoh
this it's just too
[Music]
much damn bro
what
also a longtime fan clearly with a
audio that that P Is So Graceful right Z
oh my God unreal like perfect like you
know I feel like when you hear like a
really good guitar do a solo it's all
about not going too hard right you got
to you got to set the face right exactly
buttery MH rtion and release the golden
hair it's like magic gold
yeah I have to say that that guitar is
gorgeous that pink um the Telly style
guitar he's got a nice piece yeah very
nice guitar wait can we look at it again
sure it's got a nice piece got a nice
piece got a nice package dude I think at
the end nice bro you see
it wait where
here I mean it's kind of hard to
tell mhm no that's the B during his solo
it really I think it's just back a few
frames they the one on the right there
really nice let me find the solo one on
the right solo right here yeah oh yeah
beautiful I couldn't tell if it was a
lighting thing or what so big shout out
to little
Tom absolute Shing demon on the [__]
guitar he has restraint he has talent he
has a
gift this is a tough one cuz I love
little Tom and what he's does there on
the guitar M however cardo like took me
out wait that's not against card vampir
Vampira is card was last time
yeah rewind
rewind it's rewind time as I was saying
Vampira she is a she is a mega Talent
The Vibes are Immaculate she's already
got so many F in the audience it's so
hard to decide it is close too it's very
close Fus do you have who do you who'
you vote for fidus it's interesting when
when you have multiple relation no
multiple relation I mean I had you and
then I was with holia it's interesting
how you
compare how you comp when another new
person potentially I just want to know
who you're voting for I don't you
compare what with is she more beautiful
she more cool do that have to do with
how good they
are like did you have this as well how
is all right I guess thanks for your
input there
[Music]
fous fidus thanks for hanging out on
Zoom all day by the way we're good F
interesting you can probably hang up now
thanks man we'll see you next week okay
[Applause]
buddy well as we were Goofy around here
there's 7,000 votes cast and I'm telling
you right now it was close but there is
a winner oh it's so close it's Vampira
wow vampir took it all right little Tom
you are amazing dude Mega shred shred
shred
forever yeah wait Sean penzo that's
another guy who was
uh so honored to have been the in the
running all the best oh which one was
that sha penzo was a previous uh Sean
was the uh cello
uh yeah that almost it almost made it
through that round that closest votes
Sean penzo with the golden fingers yeah
golden
fingers so um listen I got to go to the
bathroom I got to pee Oh man so I'll
just be right back it's interesting when
don't leave me with no Fus go ahead I'm
going to go to the bathroom you say
whatever you want and I'll be back okay
and then when when you have multi
relation no multiple relation I had you
and then I was with holia it's
interesting how you
compare how you comp when another new
person potentially comes in the your
life it's like you compare what if with
is she more beautiful is she more cool
is she more loving is she like did you
have this as well how
is um Lena did you want to show off your
uh teddy bear your teddy fresh teddy
bear oh a matching bear I forgot about
that yeah so
cute how you doing
Ela I'm good thank
you um I'm enjoying some
authentic um chocolate from Sweden
niceu my dad brought a whole suitcase of
candy and I'm I mean literally he
brought an excess suitcase with a bunch
of C oh my God you got that salty [__]
too uh yeah we got some there's a bunch
of bars here you guys want some oh you
have some of the salt candy I want to
try that again that's rude
[Laughter]
Zach the salty ones I I'll try the salty
one again that crypto [__] yeah yo
you're in trouble is this the one that
has the little surprise inside love
these are no surpr oh no surprise that
was the F [__] ever you were like you
gave Ethan a candy and you're like this
one has a little surprise inside and I
Hae it and he's like well what the [__]
the surprise is just more salt there's
just more salt on the inside that's
right try that sh down I love the
[__] pastries oh yeah you've been
snacking on those pastries yeah half of
the suitcase had chocolate and all the
half had the pastries is pungent I love
that oh yeah you hit that salt one mhm
these one are bro it's so salty I can't
no no wait for the sweetness do I know I
get
it it's good okay I'm starting to F but
it's bizarre cuz I don't make a face
when I do it it's like a warhead but
instead of sour it's just salt it's not
straight salt though like the kind of
salt it's like good salt you know Good
Vibes I mean I like salt but I feel like
I'm going to swell like aing perhaps
what is this perhaps let me see what is
this thank you Mr oh that's a dum suya
bro a dum suya yeah that's a dum so we
call those vacuum cleaners because they
look kind of like an old school vacuum
cleaner okay these things are [__]
awesome yeah they're busting they're
busting I know you guys go like those so
I'm going to hit the salt one now oh
yeah all right go ahead you're good oh
what is that that's the salt oh I don't
I can't do that I can't do that one that
sh too what is it salted licorice I
actually like this
all oh [__] that hell no I just tried
another one dude I feel I feel I can't
do it right now is this what like horses
eat when they need like what they call
just Li it up the chocolate good I don't
want bit mine out dude I hate salty
trees I'm seeing it I'm seeing it
through but it's a lot all right here we
go a
lot what's the life expectancy of
average break here I'll show my bump
blood pressure there's bump update
request so let's see wow oh
wow it's coming it's actually like
showing
now crazy yeah
Sam I'm trying to see it through too
but I don't need to do this to myself
what do it what does it feel like like
what are you experiencing right now it's
not that Sal here I'll take like five sh
it's not even no I I feel Ser yeah first
of all I just finished mine so nothing I
saw it through that's czy does it get
better in the middle
Dan um it gets less salty but not
entirely UNS salty the salt is
throughout it's just the uh it's the
flavors are just the initial uh burst of
saltiness it's insane that's theum
strowman of candy so bizarre cuz I don't
I don't react to it at all Sal has like
dried out your tongue or something oh J
flavor I'm curious I'm why didn't NSA
stop you with that [__] you know Umami
what Umami Umami yeah I know yeah yeah
salc it's what's in these it's the next
flavor it's coming up yeah well you
should have been
sto mommy salc I'm
ready there you go the more you know you
heard of
umami true yeah know I feel you the hawk
has spoken up and coming all right where
were we we're on our the Rip Tide versus
I am cion cion so let's get right into
it I can't breathe
[Music]
rip I at home making songs to confiding
thumbnail million miles apart but when
Dan I don't give a [__] long as I with
you I
when this one I love the be love the
Rhythm
[Music]
past I can see dream jumping on this
f i p time or
two I back
and fall in love with
you I can't breathe when you're not
there I can't breathe when you're not
there my head goes numb and my heart
beats fast when it feels like that if I
could Buton my
heart Brea when there I
Brea okay so there's Rip Tide thank you
for the uh um really good the
distractions at the end there what a
talent yeah mhm and again and he's in
the
video which I think is always courageous
when people do that I I think it's great
and I see like I said dreams jumping on
that track I'm sure of
it this was the Dark Horse I am Sion uh
the Drake nod and I do I have a soft
spot for this song I think a new song of
mine uh it's it's one of my favorite
songs never made actually and it's not
it's not released yet so hopefully at
some point it will
be you guys can sing along it's a lot of
fun to sing it's very uh it was a
written out a kind of tough time in my
life
where I don't want to explain it kind of
good
time
right I can't breath when you're not
there yo this is a this this is too
night a nightmare a nightmare I can't
you're not there you're not
there this might be
[Music]
the
you guys feel like you got to handle on
lyrics Let's see
[Music]
it I can't breathe when you're not there
you're not
there dude that that drum and Ry going
there too
dirty I can't you're not there you're
not there you're not
all right I'm going to stop it there um
we are now going to vote this is the
last bracket here of this round Rip
[Music]
Tide such an
incredible I Amion versus the Dark Horse
I am Sion yeah who wasn't even going to
be in this contact just didn't make it
pretty pretty interesting he smed right
in and I do wonder is he going to be
making it past this round jrh NBR we'll
see and based on early uh early polling
exit polling
here we are seeing a I think I Amon is
advancing wow this is a real Cinderella
Story it's interesting that is
interesting I am it's
interesting that is interesting
man no no you're good man you're good
thank you so rip Rip Tide uh is coming
in second place I Amon with 63% of the
vote wow H congratulations what a
story you know wow hey fidus you all
right
man he lovees
Cinderella like did you h this as well
how is all right thanks
buddy all right so in in the in the
interest of trying to keep this flowing
basically we've got we're in the
semifinals now right Dan uh that's right
top four we have our top four can you
add number four here yeah thank you so
we're coming up pull up the bracket if
you would please this is coming down to
the wire W that's
crazy now on this bracket cuz we just
pretty much heard them I'm going to just
give you a snippet of it to jog your
memory yeah the finals we will listen to
the whole song again okay thanks bear so
here we go this is this first
round is overwhelming oh man here we go
this is the Jersey law man everybody's
favorite verse card another favorite so
let's begin with the Jersey law man
let's get a little taste of what we uh
of what we got
[Music]
here pull me up pull me up by the roots
we've
grown oh all the things you said Keep Me
In My Head wish that I could step into
yours instead you are so close but I'm
on my own cuz I just don't know where
you that is clean man that is
clean you
[Music]
understand me in
my so that is uh the Jersey laot man
that's great
fantastic and then
cardo oh man this one is
crazy had three points on the
[Music]
subreddit nightmare a nightmare I can't
breathe when you're not there your head
goes num with my heart beat F and it
feels like
that it's hard to say
this guy is like a gen he's like a
musical genius I don't know how
anybody's going to vote it's amazing
that's track is crazy I love it I love
both of them you know I love the Jersey
law man I'm obsessed with the
man guys how are we going to vote on
this one we
have my goodness the Jersey law
man vers card here we go let's throw it
up here we go no thanks you
golly I know which one I'm voting for I
I know which one I'm voting for but like
golly it was just so close go in my
mind
wow unexpected in my opinion me too the
Jersey law man is cleaning up right now
whoa he's coming in at 66% the Jersey
law man has basically locked this up wow
I'm surprised I thought cardo was going
to win I did I was feeling Jersey Lon
you
were you're not alone I mean I love
Jersey so that's it he's advancing he's
in the final the Jersey first
finalist holy [__] man holy [__] the
lman that song makes me want to cry dude
you hear that L man it's too good it
makes you want to cry it's it's it's too
good I but Zach are you going to cry
even harder when you find out it's all
AI yeah I give up man any music
knowledge is going to be thrown the
[__] window I'm so nervous to hear
that I already know it's going to be AI
you think that guitar Solo's AI I just
feel like there's ask like that that
only makes sense yeah I got to talk to
him I have to how could it be like a
meme a meme page no and also shred also
like if you're that talented why are you
running a meme page
like there there's got to be like the
world is yours to conquer man and your
[__] posting on
Instagram I love
cardo oh I love you cardo I'm sorry you
lost I I think you're a genius the final
four are all winners in my I want to
send these all to dream to be honest
but cardo I love you all right moving on
to the next bracket we've got the the
one and only vampire girl vampir
devil the little devil the little devil
vampir little devil she's a little devil
isn't she folks I think we we all
remember hers because frankly she stands
out and that's good yeah yeah
Unforgettable
[Music]
mhm I
can't
[Music]
so anyway again just to jog your
memory that is the little devil
vanira um up next that's fine Dan um to
play devil's advocate for a second what
you don't like it
just said I'm advocating for her you
said devil I'm the devil's advocate
she's the little devil little devil oh I
see little devil we advocate for the
little devil The Devil's
Advocate all right up next is the Dark
Horse I am Sion all the way to the semi
where did he come
from here it is one more time jog it up
jog it up it's it's one of my favorite
songs ever made actually and it's not
it's not released yet so we'll play at
some point it will be
you guys can sing along it's a lot of
fun to sing it's very uh it was a ritten
out a kind of tough time in my life
where it is very I don't want to
explain I don't want to I don't want to
explain ready
go I can't breathe when you're not there
you're not there you're not there I
can't
nightm nightm there it is this is a
tough one too my friend
friends this is it this is the finals
V carefully my friends my family out
there watching who we love so well by
the way and thank you everyone for being
here and thank you to all of our members
by the way as well love and
appreciate um we have vampire Vampira
versus I am Sion the Dark Horse let's
see I know who ooh it's close
it's interesting people get your votes
in it is close interesting wow hold the
phone so vampir is in a slight
lead with 53% it is so close for
Sion wow 47% cion 50 now it's 54 53% it
keeps bumping around 53 54% Vampira 46%
I am San 5,000 votes we're going to need
more votes it's too close it's too close
to call too close to call
uh people get you can get your late
ballots in your absentee ballots we'll
count them all they need big massive
dumps big massive dumps guys get your
votes in this is seriously
important wow the audience is split I
see lots of support for for both songs
in chat but at the end of the day I'm
seeing more support for vampir the
little
devil
uh at
55% oh boy oh here's a message from
Riptide I've been tearing up all night I
can't believe I'm next to such
incredibly talented people I love y'all
so much I am cion your song is Amazing
Rip
Tide thanks rip what a class was
great it was it was one of our we love
the class so good well golly uh G
Willers you guys there's almost 8,000
votes cast and it seems pretty set it's
a 10o split I think I think the girlies
are all in on I think I've seen enough I
think I've seen enough um I see lots of
girls support girl girl
power lots of girls girls in
chat so I am s you don't know the gender
of the I Amion by way we don't gender
list idea uh queen or
King all right well vampir is going to
win 55% to 45% I am we have our final
round people we're there wow okay wow I
I love that Scion song so much I love
the Cinderella story but ultimately the
the ladies have spoken and it's a girls
it's now people say it's a man's world
it's
not it's a woman's world all you little
Devil's watching you guys created a
monster by calling that
out
all right so this is it I mean pull up
the bracket if you would please there
you are Jersey law man vers vampir x
x
unbelievable
unbelievable so let's go ahead and just
jump right over to the Jersey law man
let's give him a full
playthrough here we go listen carefully
listen with your heart and your mind
this is important this make change the
trajectory of their whole life as dream
has dream is going to be making an
official collaboration with them I
haven't asked him
yet all right here is the Jersey law
man wait wait wait are we going to have
him he well I figure there's a chance he
wins so I guess no no I mean the actual
dream yeah I should message him it's
just getting so [__] late
oh pull me up pull up by the roots
weown the youve said Keep Me In My Head
wish that I could step into yours
instead you're so close but I'm on my
own cuz I just don't know where you
go you take
my oh
[Music]
good I'm My Own I just know
where I can't Brea you're not you're
not you're
not can't sleep it's a nightmare a
nightmare
[Music]
I My head goes my hearts fast when its
feels
like
crazy
me out out from
the featuring all of her tree too you
got to
feat although most people would pay not
to have them on their
TR the things you said keep me in my
head was that I could step into yours
instead you're so close but I'm on my
own cuz I just don't know where you go
I can't breathe when you're not there
you're not there you're not there I
can't sleep it's a nightmare a nightmare
a nightmare I can't breae when you're
not there you're not there you're not
there my head goes num and my heart
beats back when it feels like that
attack
it works so well with Oliver like it
sounds better than Oliver that's why it
works looks handsome more handsome too
better looking sounds
[Music]
better it feels like
that
[Music]
God this cyber down look at that I love
this
place night
nightm I can't s it's a nightmare a
nightmare a nightmare
[Music]
nightmare
nightmare I can't breath when you're not
there you're not there you're not I
can't sleep it's a nightmare a nightmare
a nightmare I can't bring up there not
there not my heades num and my heart
beats fast when it feels like that
[Applause]
[Music]
ATT no way that's
AI right no
way Frank I don't know I have no idea
never
[Music]
tried so
but like it's perfect I feel like it was
AI there'd be more
imperfection the f are like
[Music]
uncan but like it's also too good in a
sense right Z that's a little what I
wonder like is it a little too good the
only only reason it might be AI it it
sounds very very very similar to tornado
of souls by Mega Death you think that if
you listen to that solo that that is not
note for note the tone is the same could
be which could be a complement to the
Jersey law man or it could be
AI um I'm messaging with dream right now
um has he been watching he said he he
saw a c
and so he's agreed to the deal H I
haven't asked have you sent him over the
paperwork um so in the meantime that is
the Jersey law man wow wow wow indeed
and here is my little devil Vampira
XOXO infinity and beyond that's right
panic attack
here it is your other
finalist why did that happen
nope
[Music]
I I
can't
I
[Music]
I can't breathe when you're not there
you're not there you're not there I
can't sleep it's a nightmare a nightmare
a nightmare I can't bre when you're not
there you're not there you're not there
my head goes numb and my heart beats
fast when it feels like that penut p p p
p
p p p p
p heades my heart beats fast when I
feel attack come follow me into my dark
and crew line I'm only here to tell you
all this one time to be my M to be my
and of me all the damn time I always
feel my heart be hurting my chest I
think I'm going at to Cardiac Arrest
this is an everyday reur all the pain as
[Music]
mine I can't bre when you're not there
you're not there you're not there I
can't see it's a nightmare a nightmare a
nightmare I can't not you're not there
you're not my head goes down my hearts
when its feels like that pic
[Music]
attack
all right
awesome awesome who's going to win who's
going to win I really don't know I think
we got a real uh I think we got a comp
here we man her voice is phenomenal
she's good she's got a she's a talent
and I'm I'm a long long time law man
head a law head I've been following the
law man since since like under a
thousand followers true and as coming as
somebody that doesn't like anything
being a longtime fan of him really and
particularly The Outlaw You endorsed him
before I even knew who he was yeah I was
saying I don't follow the Jersey Outlaw
on Instagram but I follow the law
the OG law man yeah did you ever think
you would see him in a musical no I had
no idea but he continuously surprises me
but the reason I brought that up is to
just emphasize though I'm a huge fan I
am very torn I I love v as well so all
right well let's throw it up everybody
please I think the audience is going to
be really your votes split on this one
too get them in the Jersey law man vers
Vampira XOXO get them in now we need
every vote counts every vote counts all
right as expected we're off to a close
start here I don't this one's going to
be really split oo
whoa very close
start excuse
me all right well this is our closest
yet um right now vampir has a slight
lead at 53% 5,000 votes cast get the
also Super Chat that was saying where is
it I think they were saying they don't
think it's AI by the way about so who
about the law men I got to I have to I
need to talk to that guy it's
interesting uh they said that 100%
uh that 100% the tornado of souls
backing track and an original solo
promis no Pi take Backes not uh not AI
my guess who said that just a Super Chat
Super Chat oh it'd be funny if it was
the law man well if if that was not AI
solo then whoever played that [__]
solo nailed the tone perfectly yeah
right but it can't be him that's
impossible it can't be all one person
the law man is closing the lead at this
moment it's 48% law man 52% Vampira oh
my God so close it's up to almost 9,000
votes so it is significant but it's too
close to call my friends Jersey
get in there vampir girls girls girls
and B mass and others get in there so
there was another Super Chat that said
they the vampir one really reminded them
of Crystal Castles I just wanted I was
thinking the same thing I don't know
that reference I don't you don't know
Boomer [__] Boomer yeah for sure that
was uh smug Anson said that was such a
hard decision both such great contenders
I know it I know it if you if you guys
want the answer on AI or not I did just
get the answer from the LA say it no
wait till after wait should we or should
we not would it change the vote what do
you guys think did we reveal the answer
I think it might people have let me say
something it is 49% law man 51% Vampira
that'ss this is nuts closing in on
10,000 so the question is do we
reveal
the source of the guitar solo or do we
wait Zach what do you think I don't know
anymore and that's what scares me about
living in this day and age you think we
should you're saying okay let's do it
all right go ahead K I said is it Ai and
they said only the faces in Oliver's
voice I sang the bit with but I sang the
bit with his voice and put his voice
over no backing track I recorded it all
it just sounds similar to that song and
I said oh my God you did the guitar solo
and said yes wow no way bro he's a liar
oh my God bro you you whatever the [__]
your name is l man I I the tone was Mo
own why are you doing dumb meme Pages
man go out there and take the World by
the horns dude you're too you're like a
caged butterfly dude go fly free I was
already like so preparing myself that
it's going to be AI that I've convinced
myself that it's going to be AI yeah
okay it's at 5050 now wow we have been
glazing up the law mans but but that
being
said uh it's
5050 this
is how is it possible can we have two
winners can we just have two winners I
would love that I think they're both so
different sometimes when I watch Project
Runway they do that well let's see let's
see that's kind of like the best moment
ever
5050 let's see let's see right now we're
closing on 11,000 votes it's 50 5050 50
still how can it be that close how
how how that solo blew my mind dude oh
my god um so here it is basically yeah
can we tell the precise number of votes
cast it doesn't tell you it's
annoying all right let's give it
percentages let's give it a little time
and see if one moves 51 um interesting
comment let dream choose the winner
yeah he I don't know I don't know if he
wants to uh he doesn't want to I don't
know if he wants to get in on this okay
5050 um if they're going to be touring
together I mean he should at least you
know pick
yeah now the Jersey law man one is Big
the graph is bigger if you look at it
it's a little bit Yeah it it oh 51 oh
there it is it has
flipped wow just like triller oh there
it is what people are saying redo the
poll
what redo the poll with new info oh the
AI info we did find out um the answer to
the question well that would just I
don't think it's going to change that
much though because I don't know how
many people are voting this on that
alone seriously calling it AI was a
disservice I mean it was a legitimate um
then speculation right in his days you
know he he definitely you know came at
this at a disadvantage with that
speculation although once we revealed
the truth it seems that some more
support rallied for
him uh he's in the lead right now 12,000
votes cast 51% Jersey law man people are
calling rig they're stealing it now hype
up Vampira like you're doing lawmen
Vampira she's she's a rock star yep I
mean
she she's going to be to she doesn't
need dreams she is she's got the X
Factor she's got it she's a great
performer she's got a beautiful voice
she's got great camera presence I really
yeah I like the video it was one shot
too yeah just that continuous thing just
one shot in the garage with the subject
matter yeah she's like out in the garage
by herself having a panic attack but
kind of but is able to get it out with
the music I I just like the whole how it
all came together with her video a lot
yeah Bo is accusing us of um putting
Waits and fish he says vampir was
definitely winning before the glaze just
saying that's from Bo she was winning
before it was confirmed that there was
no AI I think that that information is
valid to get out there if you guys want
cuz there were there are people who
won't vote for one that's AI let's do
this let's do this let's redo the poll
now that there's new information out
okay we're not going to it's I don't
let's just see what happens let's see
how it shakes out rewind changes
anything so start we are going to do
another
okay stand by the Jersey out law man
says he played the guitar I still think
two winners could be it's a talent
brother two winners can be an option two
winners can be an option I agree okay uh
final
round round
two final round super mega last final
round final final final final final
Final edit final L edit export
MP4 I used to get so many of those when
I was used to make YouTube
videos uh okay um I would just start
typing random numbers I had so much them
the Jersey law man Vampira XOXO final
round round two how long's it here we go
are you actually typing all that
[__] no final round round two so people
this is it let's see now this is final
final this is final final no
takeback so people get your votes in it
is very
close it's and actually now it's
tightening because in the beginning now
the law man's back up the law man is
back up to 54 it just went down to 53
5347 girls get your votes in girls girls
Vampira heads Little Devils little devil
heads all you Devils out there get your
votes in let's R some support for vampir
the goth girles goth girls get your
votes in you're not a girls girl if you
don't vote for vampir what you doing
what are you doing you're a phony
baloney oh man 53% law man right now
7,000 that okay I I I kind of did
because of the the Revelation it it
definitely was a
detering element for some people people
really like the idea of two winners but
uh listen I like that IDE I think I like
it too mainly because the prize is a
thing that is not necessarily really
happening anyways so what difference
does it make to just say they both
win well I mean I guess it could happen
it's could it's going to happen although
based on my text conversation with him
it doesn't seem like it will that will
ever happen what happened should have
happened what should have happened so
then what difference
that the text combo I had didn't go
exactly how I hoped oh no frankly that
happen well read this
I would say bad but it's not it's not a
fun outcome I'll say that
uhoh what's your gauge on that one
there uh yeah I don't know yeah what
happened should have happened what
happened should have happened here's
what I'll do here's what I'll do I was
going to give the winner $500 because I
am a g I am one of the guys so then two
winners for sure so two winners each
gets $500 y because we honor you both
win you both win you both win and I
don't want it's close though it's
getting even closer it's 52% jury law
man I think they both win
yeah yeah so each each of you guys is
going to get
$500 from me one of the good guys out
here I'm a good capitalist remember that
left this when the yeah you teens come
out my neighbors definitely aren't as
rich as generous as me so let's get him
in the street before me thank
you is that too violent what do you mean
or just like the French Revolution they
cut off everyone's head oh I just don't
understand so once once there's a
leftist revolution and we become the
Communist
Utopia they're going to want to kill
people that you know that chop off my
head basically when the revolution comes
and I was We were supposed to get all of
that I don't know was that clear I felt
like it was clear yeah okay wow
congratulations you guys can we talk to
either or both of them
both to congratulate them on what a the
first time we've had a double header
winner I think in the history of our
tournaments mhm it is 5:30 yes it's
quite quite quite quite
late and these tournaments always do go
very very very very very very very um
have we we've made contact with the law
man have we made contact with we haven't
heard from her what if we well we didn't
try we didn't try to yeah what AB just
said why don't we talk to them both on
Monday yeah yep yep yep okay and I'll
I'll get some time to um you know put my
uh you know my magic to the T t on
dream and convince him to officially
license the song yeah work your charm
over the weekend I a work my charm
either way I'm sure it'll be good
content yeah For Better or Worse well I
want to say um congratulations
congratulations to both both of you
Juggernaut you Titans in the music
industry and also to the the runners up
I mean my goodness the two that I really
Lov so much are the um the card I don't
know that one crazy that one was crazy
and then the other one was um the the
darkh horse one the uh I Amon I Amon I
like that one a lot too
yeah so there it is guys thank you
everyone really wow wow wow we'll do a
little introspection on Monday thank you
so much everybody a long day so much
talent I'm going to send these all to
dream
and I'll send him with a message you
can't refuse send him with an offer you
can't
refuse um nice to meet Hawkin thank you
so much for coming out thank you thank
you and we'll see you on Monday and
Wednesday and
Friday I can where's he gonna be on
Monday you gonna force him to stay at
home or he he gonna sit on I'll give
I'll give him the car he's gonna do some
whatever I don't know but don't do that
for me he's welcome here right yeah but
he's busy on
Monday oh yeah you're busy
yeah
no that's that's it we'll also work this
out over the week no we'll work okay all
right anyhoo thank you everybody uh have
a great weekend a phenomenal weekend
yeah stay safe a jubilant
weekend stay safe stay hydrated and
remember at least you're not Ryan
Kavanagh
good night everybody keep shredding keep
shredding good night
[Music]
everybody